bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat après avoir entendu la
semaine dernière l'ancien directeur du
FMI Dominique stroskan la commission
d'enquête sénatoriale sur le rôle des
banques dans l'évasion fiscale a
poursuivi hier ses auditions elle a
entendu deux journalistes Antoine payon
journaliste à La Croix et auteur d'un
livre intitulé ces 600 milliards qui
manquent à la France enquête sur
l'évasion fiscale mais également Fabrice
Harfi journaliste à miaap qui est à
l'origine de la révélation de l'affaire
Cusac retour donc ce matin sur ces deux
auditions bonne matinée à tous nous
allons entendre cet après-midi j'allais
dire une nouvelle fois puisque vous avz
déjà été entendu par la présente la
précédente commission qui ne portait pas
d'ailleurs sur le même spectre euh
Monsieur Antoine payon qui est
journaliste à La Croix alors euh
monsieur vous avez désormais un peu
l'habitude vous savez que vous allez
devoir prêter serment donc euh Monsieur
Antoine payon prêtez-vous serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
levez la main droite et dites je le jure
je le jure je vous remercie beaucoup
euh comme c'est l'usage je vous propose
que euh dans un intervalle de temps
d'environ 10 minutes un quart d'heure si
vous voulez dépasser les 10 minutes vous
nous retraciez ce que vous avez envie de
nous dire sur notre sujet et en tout cas
ce qui vous paraît nécessaire que nous
entendions après quoi notre rapporteur
Éric boket vous
posera différentes questions sur ce
point afin d'affiner vos réponses ou
d'élargir le débat ce qui sera également
l'œuvre de des membres de la commission
ici présent alors Monsieur Vous AVEZ LA
PAROLE merci monsieur le
Président je m'appelle donc Antoine
payon je suis journaliste grand reporter
au au quotidien La Croix et j'ai publié
c'est la date de parution en mars à la
fin mars 2012 un livre dont le le titre
est C 600 milliards qui manqueent à la
France enquête au cœur de l'évasion
fiscale et qui était une une sorte de
plongée en profondeur est très précise
sur l'organisation de la fraudte fiscale
par la banque UBS la banque suisse sur
le territoire français des années au
moins 2004 mais peut-être en amont déjà
dès le la création de cette banque en
l'an 2000 jusque l'année 2011 puisque
les derniers événements que j'ai retracé
dataient de de cette année 2011 avec un
cœur disons un cœur une intensité
particulière dans les années 2004 euh à
l'année
2007 j'ai
enquêté à partir de l'été 2011 très
précisément et pendant un peu plus de de
6 mois de façon très
intensive j'ai pu récolter du fait de
nombreuses sources à la fois judiciaire
au sens large c'est-à-dire d'abord des
policiers ensuite des magistrats mais
aussi de de sources internes à la banque
UBS que ce soit à Paris en France ou que
ce soit en Suisse une somme assez
considérable de documents
internes qui permettait de de tracer
très précisément à la fois les modalités
de l'organisation de cette fraudte
fiscale et puis évidemment les personnes
concernées soit en tant que client soit
en tant qu'acteur au sein de de cette
banque que ce soit des acteurs Suisse
puisqu'il y avait de nombreux acteurs
suisses qui venaientent en toute
illégalité faire des affaires de
récolte de de fonds financiers sur notre
territoire soit des acteurs français qui
étaient en appui des acteurs financiers
français qui étaient en appui de leurs
collègu Suisse j'ai pu au-delà de de de
ce point très focalisé sur une banque
cert emblématique je me suis attaché à
essayer de dresser un paysage plus large
du phénomène global de de ce que j'ai
appelé mais c'était un peu déjà la
pratique courante l'évasion fiscale
sous-entendu la fraude fiscale
internationale les avoirs financiers non
déclarés qui sont récoltés recelés euh
sur des comptes dans des paradis fiscaux
et pour un tiers d'entre eux en masse en
en Suisse et donc j'ai essayé de dresser
aussi le paysage général du phénomène
j'ai rencontré des de nombreuses sources
financières j'ai rencontré un économiste
qui qui fait autorité sur le sujet et je
suis arrivé à une évaluation qui a été
ensuite très
largement validé d'une d'une d'un avoir
d'environ 600 milliards d'euros manquant
à la France confondant à la fois les
avoirs des personnes physiques et des et
les avoirs des des personnes morales en
en capital disons et d'une fuite
annuelle estimée je l'estimais à
l'époque mais c'était une estimation
prudente à 30 milliards d'euros au moins
de de de somm non déclaré annuellement
au fisque français qui était donc sous
statut d'évasion fiscale dans un flux
continuel j'ai évidemment à la suite de
lapparution de de ce livre constater que
première chose des enquêtes judiciaires
qui n'avaient pas eu lieu ont été
déclenché que un travail politique
d'abord une commission d'enquête par
parlementaire mais elle avait commencé
avant au Sénat produisait de très
importantes informations et qui me
semblait converger avec ce que j'avais
pu percevoir par un petit bout de la
lorgniette et puis j'ai bien vu qu'à la
suite de ça l'opinion publique mes
confrères et notamment mes confrères de
la presse audiovisuelle mais un certain
nombre de confrères de presse écrite
s'intéressaient au sujet le
développaient menaient leurs propres
enquêtes à fondissait ma propre enquête
vous allez je crois voir tout à l'heure
un journaliste de du site méiaapart qui
a produit lui aussi et dans une période
tout récente des des enquêtes
importantes sur la même banque UBS mais
parce que elle est très représentative
des pratiques de nombreuses autres
banques peut-être avec une intensité
très particulière ce que j'ai vu pour
faire court parce que j'ai continué
c'est le droit de suite des journalistes
donc j'ai continué de fréquenter
assdument mes différentes sources les
sources judiciaires mais surtout les
sources bancaires et elles se sont
d'ailleurs augmentées parce que quand
vous révélerz quelque chose et bien de
nouvelles personnes se signalent comme
ayant des informations complémentaires
donc j'ai en quelque sorte
élargi depuis ce mois de mars 2012
jusqu'à aujourd'hui mon champ de
perception du du phénomène y compris en
particulier sur la la banque UBS mais
sur d'autres banques aussi et et j'ai pu
me mesurer
progressivement que ce que je croyais
déjà assez considérable en mars 2012
était en fait un un phénomène quasi
systématique très très généralisé dans
le milieu bancaire pas seulement Suisse
avait une importance en terme économique
et financier qui était considérable et
que et bien le phénomène était loin
d'être en assèchement en extinction que
malgré les enquêtes judicies malgré le
travail des parlementaires que ce soit
ici au Sénat que ce soit à l'Assemblée
nationale malgré je pense un
commencement de travail gouvernemental
pour essayer de de de contenir le le
phénomène et bien ce la pratique de
l'évasion fiscale était en faisait
floresse et produisait toujours plus de
chiffres d'affaires et de et de
bénéfices du système bancaire mais pas
seulement parce que le système bancaire
est peut-être le cœur d'un système plus
large aux banques sont articulés des
cabinets
d'avocats des conseillers financiers des
notaires on les voit apparaître par
exemple dans l'affaire vildinstein voilà
un ensemble de de un ensemble de
services qui ne sont pas que des
services strictement financiers mais qui
tous concour à faire en sorte que à la
fois des entreprises et il y a parfois
des liens et des personnalités physique
chef d'entreprise
euh bien entendu beaucoup dans les
professions libérales à haut revenus
bien entendu beaucoup dans ce qu'on
appelle le
showbsiness le sport professionnel et
bien que au service de ces très très
nombreuses personnes il y a une
véritable industrie ce sont les termes
d'un expert qui travaille pour la revue
projet il y a une véritable industrie de
de l'évasion fiscale c'est une industrie
je conclus là-dessus parce que je crois
que ça peut vous intéresser que c'est
une des dimensions que quelqu'un que
vous avez auditionné déjà qui est Pierre
Condamin Gerbier nous a révélé dans
toute son ampleur le le 29 mai dernier à
moi-même à Fabrice Harfi que vous voyez
tout à l'heure et à Edou Plenel et bien
il nous a montré comment au tournant des
années 90 au milieu des années 90 des
entreprises des groupes qui étaient des
groupes commerciaux et industriels ont
créé eux-mêmes leur propres banque dans
des par paradis fiscaux notamment
anglo-saxon de façon d'une part à gérer
leurs propres affaires euh à l'abri du
fisque des pays sur lesquels ils
opéraient leur chiffres d'affa et se
sont rendus compte que le rendement
économique était tellement
extraordinaire qu'ils ont opéré une
sorte de mutation économique et qu'ils
ont ils se sont spécialisés dans ces ces
banques parfois de taille très réduite
mais très très très efficace et articulé
la plupart du temps à d'autres grands
opérateurs financiers des grandes
banques comme UBS Crédit Suisse en
Suisse mais chez nous des grandes
banques françaises aussi on entend bien
entendu parler d'HSBC voilà il y a
vraiment un moment historique que je ne
connaissais pas au moment où j'ai
enquêté pour mon livre que j'ai
découvert depuis et qui fait bien
l'articulation euh du système financier
du des services financier avec en
réalité l'économie ce qu'on appelle
l'économie réelle il n'y a pas je l'ai
compris assez tardivement il n'y a pas
une rupture il n'y a pas une dissension
entre l'économie dit réel et l'activité
financière y compris quand elle est
offshore non déclaré voir éventuellement
grise ou noir il y a une articulation
historique très forte et il y a une
articulation organisationnelle très
forte que je pourrais peut-être un petit
peu détailler si vous le le souhaitez
voilà peut-être pour focaliser un peu
sur votre interrogation je c'est une
façon de vous mettre en garde peut-être
sur le fait que les banques ne sont
qu'un instrument les banques ne sont
queun outil les fraudeurs ce sont
d'abord les clients au sens large du
terme ça peut être d'ailleurs de très
grands groupes c'est des personnalités
évidemment aussi très fortunées parfois
très très connu du grand public et et
c'est elles qui d'abord sont les ce sont
elles les fraudeurs après les banques
évidemment elles se mettent parfois dans
l'illégalité mais comme un comme un
outil ou un
instrument qui n'est pas légal ne reste
qu'un instrument et un outil et à côté
de cet outil là mais je crois que déjà
vos vos travaux précédents l'ont montré
il y a bien d'autres outils articulés
les les les assurances vie les
trust voilà toute une palette de
services entre guillemets financiers qui
ne sont pas que des
banques merci beaucoup monsieur je vais
passer immédiatement la parole à notre
rapporteur bien merci monsieur le
Président donc merci Monsieur pon
d'avoir accepté c'est notre nouvelle
invitation pour cette nouvelle
commission d'enquête donc qui s'inscrit
bien sûr dans la droite ligne de ce que
nous avons mené comme travail l'an
dernier avec l'ensemble de nos collègues
sur l'évasion fiscale au sens général
mais là effectivement nous intéressons
davantage à la machinerie la mécanique
et donc bien sûr les banques mais aussi
les acteurs financiers he c'est dans
l'intitulé de la commission d'enquête et
qui inclut à l'évidence les les les
opérateurs les intervenants que vous
avez cité dans votre propos et nous
partageons complètement cette cette
préoccupation alors vous aviez été
auditionné l'an dernier dans cette
commission d'enquête il y a à peu près
un an alors bien sûr nous n'allons pas
refaire le même travail même si le
contenu avait été très utile très
éclairant extrêmement intéressant de la
vie unanime des des sénateurs qui
avaient participé à ces travaux mais
vous l'avez évoqué il faut le rappeler
beaucoup d'événements dont certains
considérables sont intervenus dans la
dernière période qui ont apporter un
nouvel éclairage et qui font que avec
d'autres éléments qui ont été rappelés
le regard de l'opinion au sens large
n'est plus le même que celui qu'il était
il y a un an à l'évidence donc loin de
mon esprit d'imaginer que le problème
est jugulé loin sen faut mais je pense
que est en train de se construire
quelque chose qui se construit lentement
dans l'opinion en France et même
international sur ce sujet qui le rend
donc plus sensible et quelque part
incontournable au plan politique donc je
pense qu'il faut qu'on puisse s'appuyer
là-dessus pour pour avancer et donc
j'aimerais bon vous avez rappelé votre
ouvrage qui a fait date évidemment sur
ce sujet dont il a été beaucoup
questions qui a été beaucoup commenté
qui a apporté beaucoup d'informations
extrêmement utiles intéressante euh mais
est-ce que vous pourriez revenir sur la
question des des gripages entre
guillemets des difficultés que vous avez
pu constater dans les procédures de
contrôle puisque notre commission
d'enquête envisage également
indépendamment du rôle des banques et
les acteurs financiers les procédure
existant en matière de contrôle de
supervision de régulation quel est votre
regard sur cette question là donc les
les gripages on va les appeler ainsi euh
et y compris dans le cours des
procédures judiciaires vous avez évoqué
l'affaire UBS voilà un élément nouveau
qui n'était pas enclenché l'an dernier
aujourd'hui depuis avril 2012 en tout
cas le le la justice s'intéresse à
l'affaire et des avancées ont été
constatées voilà et je poserai la même
question pour le le traitement fiscal
des fichiers dont il a été question
également à propos d'une enquête
l'enquête offshore leak par exemple et
d'autres voilà j'aimerais avoir votre
appréciation sur ces points dans un
premier temps si vous voulez bien
monsieur payon bien
sûr la question du du contrôle
habituellement appelé dans la profession
le contrôle prudentiel qui est un
contrôle
institutionnalisé sous autorité de la
Banque de France premièrement à travers
son bras armé qui est l'Autorité de
contrôle prudentiel donc qui est chargé
de vérifier la conformité
des des procédures bancaires et des
assurances à la loi française à a
présenté un visiblement un un un
dysfonctionnement à à à manifester un
dysfonctionnement au moins en tout cas
dans l'affaire UBS l'unanimité de mes
sources et notamment de de mes sources
internes ont affirmé qu'elles ont tenté
d'alerter cette autorité de contrôle
prudentiel de la Banque de France très
tôt
après la découverte par eux-mêmes des
délit qu'ils constataent dans leur
propre banque ça a commencé à Strasbourg
dès l'année
2008 ça a été un échec de pour le
directeur de l'établissement
UBS de Strasbourg c'était le directeur
lui-même qui ayant constaté ça
souhaitait en faire part à l'autorité de
contrôle prudenciel il n'a jamais eu
accès à cette autorité de contrôle ça a
été ensuite un groupe ement de de cadres
supérieurs à la tête duquel on peut dire
que l'auditeur interne de l'époque
Nicolas Fiss on peut aujourd'hui citer
son nom il est il est maintenant ce qui
n'était pas le cas il y a un an il est
maintenant bien connu ont plusieurs fois
alerté cette même autorité de contrôle
prudentiel à Paris y compris par des
courriers et ils ont été il a été
nécessaire de multiplier par trois ces
courriers et surtout de faire quelques
d'organiser quelques Fues dans la presse
pour que cette autorité de contrôle
prudentiel déclenche sa propre enquête
première chose et deuxième chose
transmette très rapidement au parquet de
Paris au procureur de Paris les éléments
qui lui étaient livrés tout simplement
qui étaient suffisamment importants
grave et et et et probant pour que ça ne
puisse pas être retenu plus longtemps
par l'Autorité de contrôle prudentiel et
donc il y a ce premier point c'est il y
a au moins 2 ans au moins 2 ans de perdu
par cette autorité contrôle prudentiel
dans euh l'enquête la vérification et
éventuellement la sanction puisque c'est
un de ses pouvoirs des malversations
opéré au sein de du BS c'est extrêmement
dommageable parce que ça a deux
conséquences lourdes immédiates la
première c'est que dès que une direction
d'une banque comme celle-ci comprend que
il y a péril éventuel de d'une enquête
d'un contrôle et bien elle se livre tout
simplement la destruction de preuve elle
se livre à un ce qu'on appelle un
nettoyage de l'ensemble de ces fichiers
et avec une brutalité d'ailleurs qui
fait que elle a même demandé à l'une de
de ces cadres qui pourtant protestaient
contre l'évasion fiscale de faire
elle-même le nettoyage de ces fichiers
il s'agit de Stéphanie gibaau qui était
la directrice des relations publiques de
cette banque depuis sa création à Paris
donc il y a eu d'abord ce
nettoyage et puis la deuxième chose
c'est que les témoins potentiel les
cadres qui étaient quand même une
dizaine qui n'acceptaient pas ces
procédures illégales et bien on tous
dans la même période moment où ils ont
signalé et moment où l'Autorité de
contrôle prudentiel s'est déclenché ils
ont tous été sortis de la banque li
licencié et donc en quelque sorte un peu
perdu comme témoin interne de ce qui s'y
passait voilà un premier volet qui
permet de s'interroger sur le la
vocation ou le le l'entraint réel de
cette autorité de contrôle prudentiel
mais de toutes celles qui lui sont
attachées sur le contrôle réel des
banques et des
assurances un événement tout
récent moi m'interroge aussi et en a
interrogé d'autres c'est la la la
sanction de la banque UBS par cette même
autorité de contrôle prudentielle à
hauteur d'une amende de 10 millions
d'euros alors évidemment dans dans dans
la poche de un sénateur comme d'un
journaliste 10 millions d'euros on se
dit c'est énorme
oui je fais pas partie de ceux qui
pensent que l'engagement en tant que
parlementaire est fait pour faire
fortune mais que c'est un service à la
nation et et au peuple français donc
voilà je pour vous répondre très
clairement et donc ces 10 millions
d'euros et bien ils ont impressionné
évidemment un certain nombre de
personnes mais toutes les personnes qui
connaissent on dit ça aurait pu être
largement le décuple
étant donné que le chiffrage minimum de
ce qu' a représenté l'évasion fiscale
organisée par UBS en France sur les
quelques années dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure et d'au moins 850
millions d'euros alors une source mieux
informée que celle que j'avais pu
exploité en France une source Suisse m'a
rectifié le chiffre il y a peu m'a dit
que c'était au moins 1 milliard d'euros
donc quand on fait le rapport entre 10
millions d'euros d'amende par rapport à
1 milliard pour faire gros euh de
Bénéfic ou de chiffres d'affaires plutôt
sur l'évasion fiscale le rapport n'est
pas si impressionnant que ça et puis il
y a les attendus de la sanction qui
permettent de penser que bon il y a eu
négligence dans la vigilance mais que
tout ça c'était euh à l'inconnu de leur
plein gris et que bon ce qui ne tient
pas la route une seule seconde par
rapport à ce que j'en connais et
là-dessus je suis totalement catégorique
c'est-à-dire une organisation
industrielle systématique et
parfaitement contrôlée de l'évasion
fiscale qui était pour cette banque-là
en tout cas une activité cruciale une
activité quasiment première donc là
encore même les années les quelques
années où ça a commencé à chauffer d'un
point de vue judiciaire et du point de
vue de l'opinion publicque je vois une
autorité de contrôle prudentiel que je
juge je me le permets mais voilà comme
un observateur que je trouve bien timide
par rapport à la gravité du phénomène
elle a le pouvoir elle a le pouvoir de
de de retirer la licence d'une banque
elle a le pouvoir de décupler la
sanction dont on pécunière dont on
parlait tout à l'heure et pour finir sur
l'Autorité de contrôle prudentiel le
président actuel du BS France Monsieur
delus très récemment
démissionné du Conseil
d'État où il a eu des fonctions très
importantes a immédiatement eu comme
réflexe de dire qu'il allait faire appel
en quelque sorte de cette décision de
l'utor éé de contrôle prudentiel auprès
du Conseil d'État
ou à ma connaissance il a encore
d'excellentes relations voire même il y
a en bloc mais vous le savez il y a un
témoin qui connaît ça parfaitement bien
il y a dans l'ensemble des autorités de
contrôle prudentiel de notre pays de
nombreuses personnes issues des banques
qui travaillent parfois encore y compris
du BS France donc il y a une sorte de
porositéè très étrange en tout cas au
regard de la séparation des pouvoirs
entre le secteur financier et le secteur
du contrôle du secteur financier du
contrôle public voilà je finis donc sur
ce point par rapport à aux autorités de
contrôle prudentiel et puis il y a le
problème
judiciaire vous le savez bien et mon
livre a été brutal voire peut-être un
peu excessivement brutal à l'endroit de
d'un magistrat un vice-procureur
il j'ai pris le risque personne ne m'a
démenti de dénoncer le fait que y
compris au niveau du parquet il y avait
eu une sorte de lenteur ou de
nonchalance et d'indifférence à ce qui
avait été transmis en
2010 par justement l'Autorité de
contrôle prudentiel mais sous la
pression de divulgation dans la presse
et que il a fallu attendre une
alternance politique immédiatement en
vue et il a fallu attendre l'apparition
d'un petit livre d'un journaliste pour
que je je le dis pas à la légère je le
dis parce que cela m'a été dit j'en ai
eu le témoignage interne au parquet de
Paris et aussi au pôle financier du
tribunal de grande instance de Paris
c'est c'est ces faitsl sont pasant il a
fallu ces deux facteurs l'un étant bien
plus important évidemment et
incomparable par rapport à l'autre mais
il a fallu ces deux facteurs pour que le
procureur de Paris pense qu'il était
nécessaire de faire ouvrir enfin
d'ouvrir enfin une véritable information
judiciaire qui a été confiée à ce
moment-là à un magistrat de très très
grande qualité monsieur Guillaume daev
qui d'ailleurs étant donné l'ampleur du
dossier pour ce qui concerne UBS il en
traite d'autres s'est vu accompagner
rapidement par un autre juge
d'instruction de très très grand de très
grande valeur qui est Monsieur Serge
tourner voilà mais il a fallu là encore
très tardivement attendre que ça fasse
scandale pour que une véritable
information judiciaire çaa pu être une
instruction judiciaire soit déclenchée
avec quoi comme
conséquence et je crois être pas mal
placé pour pouvoir vous l'affirmer bien
avec le fait que la récolte desépreuves
est devenue une mission quasi impossible
là encore du temps à passé là encore des
fichiers ont été écrasés il a fallu
d'ailleurs je crois savoir et ce n'a pas
été divulgué par la presse qu'il y ait
une perquisition spécifique à motif
informatique conduite par Monsieur daef
pour constater non pas qu'on pouvait
récupérer des fichiers mais pour
constater que des instruments
informatiques avaient été manipuler dans
l'objectif d'effacer des
preuves donc c'est encore une fois une
véritable de mon point de vue un peu
primaire une une véritable entrave à la
justice le fait que ça a tardé et puis
j'ai récolté et j'ai pris le risque de
le publier et je n'ai jamais été démenti
j'ai pris le risque de considérer qu'il
y avait des motifs
à ces lenteurs ces nonchalances voir ces
empêchements de de laisser la justice
passer sur ces affaires et là on m'a
expliqué ce sont des sources ce sont des
fonctionnaires de très haut niveau dans
un monde où en général on rigole pas
beaucoup le renseignement intérieur en
particulier qui m'ont expliqué que ils
savaient bien et ils connaissaient très
précisément le fait que il y avait entre
certaines activités politiques voir
certaines personnalités politiques et
certains grands fraudeurs des relations
coupables qui faisaient que ces grands
fraudeurs il fallait parfois ne pas les
entraver dans leur fraude les gêner
sinon les relations amicales voir les
relations de supporter à supporter
risquait d'être détérioré voilà j'ai
pris le risque d'écrire ça en Nant assez
précisément un une parce que c'était le
c'était les fêes hein sur en tout cas ce
qui m'était accessible plutôt un camp
politique et une personnalité politique
éminente il s'agissait du du président
précédent président de la de la
République euh mais j'ai bien constaté
depuis et l'affaire cahusa nous a
éclairé aussi cette année que il y avait
là euh des pratiques qui ne sont pas
systématiques qui ne sont pas
forcément la représentation de la vie
politique française mais qui sont
suffisamment lourde pour avoir des
conséquences
judiciaires qui ont ensuite en
elles-même du fait de leur impuissance
l'appareil judiciaire des conséquences
sur les pratiques d'évasion fiscale qui
sont en quelque sorte
impunies les
grippages je pense que on est dans un
pays où on peut avoir une une
institution comme la Cour des comptes
qui à ma connaissance a vient de
terminer a dû terminer un rapport
certain très intéressant sur qu'est-ce
qui dans l'administration française et
notamment du côté du ministère des
Finances a pu là aussi en représenter
des gênes voire des entraves à la
connaissance du phénomène bon qu'est-ce
qui enera du rapport de ces deux
rapporteurs que je connais bien de la
Cour des comptes l'une étant d'ailleurs
une ancienne magistrate collègue de de
Guillaume DAF je suis tout à fait prêt à
à vous donner ce rapport excusez-moi il
doit sortir enfin il doit paraître
bientôt il est normalement premis
apparution pour la rentrée prochaine la
rentrée scolaire prochaine mais les les
personnes enfin les les rapporteurs
m'avaient dit que après les les vacances
de pâqu de cette année le travail avait
fini de faire la navette y compris dans
les administrations pour enrichissement
correction avis des administrations il
est terminé ce rapport je je regrette
que une commission comme la vôtre n''est
pas eu un accès forcément immédiat ou
naturel si vous nous indiquez si vous
nous indiquez que il
paraîtra début septembre en fin à la
rentrée notre commission sera encore
saisie c'est parfait donc on aura la
possibilité d'y avoir accès mais
effectivement à ce jour nous n'y avons
pas eu accès c'est également normal il
est pas publié c'est la Cour des comptes
mais si vous dites que ce sera septembre
nous nous ne sommes nous ne serons pas d
saaisis à cette date et donc voilà il y
a quand même je n'ai pas été le seul et
mes sources ont pas été les seuls à
s'interroger sur ces fameux grippages
dont parlait monsieur le rapporteur tout
à l'heure
euh juste pour finir tous ces grippages
et c'est un peu la question maintenant
de quelle méthode utiliser pour lutter
contre tous ces grippages montrent bien
que même quand la justice agit même
quand le contrôle agit il est en retard
c'est pas c'est pas des métro là c'est
ce sont des trains de marchandis qui
peuvent faire tout le la ligne PLM voilà
ils sont en retard le travail judiciaire
et le travail de contrôle est en retard
souvent de plusieurs années par rapport
au au fait même de des fraudes et que ça
laisse tout loisir au fraudeur de
naviguer en permanence de paradis
fiscaux en paradis fiscaux d'effacer des
trac de sorte à ce que les fraudes
soient invisibles soient complètement
occulté aux yeux de ceux qui
souhaiteraiit les les réprimer ou les
arrêter j'ai eu euh de ce point de vue a
la chance d'avoir été invité à l'automne
dernier à l'École nationale de la
magistrature euh par un magistrat qui à
mon avis sur le sujet passionnant c'est
le juge Charles Pratz et il y avait dans
la session de formation c'était une
session de formation il y avait une
quarantaine presque une ou une bonne
quarantaine de personnes euh procureurs
y compris des DomTom euh juges
d'instruction policiers de haut niveau
et qui tous ont raconté la même chose et
c'était très vif comme propos parce
qu'ils étaient assez énervés les uns les
autres c'est qu'ils ne n'ont jamais
aucun résultat sur le front de la fraude
fiscale pour deux raisons primo ce que
je viens de vous indiquer et lur
deuxième chose que notre loi n'est pas
formatée pour réprimer la fraude fiscale
alors il ruse avec la fameuse formule du
blanchiment mais vous imaginez que
d'abord il faut qu'il ait blanchiment
puis deuxième chose voilà de toute façon
y compris les peine sont tellement
minimes par rapport au forfait quand il
y a condamnation que même des fraudeurs
pris en flagrant délit et je vous prie
de m'excuser pour ça mais un très grand
fraudeur en tout cas par rapport au
responsabilité politique qu'il a eu
jusqu'à il y a pas très longtemps
peuvent se permettre et il y en avait
même encore un autre à la télévision
hier soir paraî-il sur France 2 peuvent
se permettre une arrogance qui fait in
jure mais ils ne risque rien qui fait in
jure à la démocratie à la
République mais c'est un propos déjà un
peu engagé qui est mon
sentiment monsieur voilà sur les
gripages monsieur le rapporteur
oui pour toujours pour élargir le propos
au-delà des des banques des acteurs
financiers est-ce que vous pourriez dans
la mesure où vous Enez des éléments
d'information là-dessus détailler
l'organisation financière des
entreprises dites non financières qui
sont aussi des acteurs importants sur le
sujet est-ce que vous aurez des éléments
explicatifs illustratif sur ce
sujet j'ai j'ai les éléments que j'ai
monsieur le rapporteur ur ce sont c'est
le récit c'est une sorte de récit qui
m'a été fait par Ben vous l'avez
auditionné donc par Pierre Condamin
Gerbier le 29 mai
dernier sur le début de sa carrière et
comment il commence au milieu des années
90 à être au service de grande
famillille armateur grande famille
commerciale de de commerce sur la
Méditerranée et comment rapidement ces
famille lui demande de faire participer
au montage de structures financières et
bancaires notamment
jersey donc dans les paradis fiscaux
dépendant de la Couronne britannique et
il nous a bien expliqué très longuement
comment il y a une sorte de deuxième
activité dans lequel l'expertise est
très rapidement mobilisée parce que ils
ont les moyens du fait voilà de des
chiffres d'affaires formidables qu'ils
font dans le commerce de mobiliser des
cabinets d'experts des avocats beaucoup
des avocats profession d'avocat
notamment il y a une dizaine de cabinets
parisiens qui sont vraiment très très
performants en la matière leur
permettent de faire des montages tout
simplement de de créer des des sociétés
bancaires et on crée pas des sociétés
bancaires aussi facilement à tel ou tel
endroit en
Suisse étant donné votre honorabilité
vous n'auriez pas de difficulté à à à
faire rapidement une banque ce n'est pas
difficile de monter une banque et donc
on fait une banque avec tous les
avantages maintenant quelques
inconvénients depuis peu d'années mais
tous les avantages que ça comportait
c'est-à-dire des comptabilités euh hors
contrôle en quelque sorte en tout cas
dans certains pays dont la Suisse
euh voilà j'ai eu le réci précis de de
ça euh ce que j'en ai retiré c'est qu'il
y avait euh pour
ces sociétés mais attaché parfois des
des familles mais c'est souvent le cas
dans les grandes affaires industrielles
y compris de de notre pays il y avait la
mobilisation de nombreux experts et que
les chiffres d'affaires et les résultats
permettaient de mobiliser des expertises
très très étoffées très étoffées alors
le détail après ben c'estel les cabinets
d'avocat je vais pas les citer les
enquêtes sont en cours mais nous avons
oui il a il y a des experts en la
matière je pense que un avocat très très
proche d'un ancien ministre un assez
ancien ministre qui encore défrait la
chronique jusqu'à hier soir sur France 2
fait partie de ce monde des avocats
spécialisés dans les montages offshore
non décl
ils sont experts sur Singapour
maintenant sur Hong Kong voilà tout ça
n'est pas d'ailleurs si difficile que ça
mais il y a il y a ces montages je je
vous réponds peut-être pas assez
précisément monsieur le rapporteur sur
le sur le le
sujet c'est parce que il y a pas de il y
a parfois pas tant de complication que
ça je vous décris une chose très simple
en 2005 mais c'est resté valable je
pense jusqu'à il y a à peine 2 ans la
gestion des avoirs non déclarés par la
banque UBS à Genève en tout cas mais je
crois que c'était valable à B à Zuri à
Lausanne se faisait dans des boîtes en
bois et avec des fiches cartonnées et un
système informatique qui était qui était
infin articulé à ces données
strictement strictement matériel papier
et donc facile à détruire comme
d'ailleurs les carnet du lait pour les
comptabilités de récolte sur les pays
étrangers dans une première boîte les
les boîtes sont sont chaque chaque
gestionnaire chaque conseiller financier
on appelle ça des chargés d'affaires à
Genève ils était une bonne cinquantaine
au 4e étage du siège du BS à deux boîtes
dans une première boîte il y a le nom
réel du client et son pseudonyme et dans
la deuxième boîte il y a le pseudonyme
et le numéro du compte numéro
informatique du
compte quand on veut gérer les affaires
de telle ou telle personne ou de telle
ou telle personne morale et bien d'abord
on connaît ses clients chaque chaque
chargé d'affaires a environ 500 400 300
400 500 gros clients et bien il regarde
il reçoit un coup de téléphone avec un
pseudonyme parce que les gens
fonctionnent avec pseudonyme il
regardent à qui ça correspond il
comprend de quoi il s'agit il se
rapporte au numéro des Comptes qui sont
gérés pour ces personnes et il rentre à
ce moment-là dans le système
informatique qui lui ne connaît que des
numéros voilà c'est comme ça que
fonctionne de façon très artisanale d'où
d'ailleurs toute la terminologie
pastorale de nos amis suisses sur carnet
du lait fichier vache c'est que quelque
part c'est c'est très très très
prosaïque et très matérialisé mais très
destructible parce que autant les
banques de données informatiques les
serveurs tout ça si on n'est pas
informaticien on peut laisser traîner
des choses autant détruire des petites
fiches cartonnées faire ce nettoyage des
archives papiers ça n'est pas si
difficile que ça voilà donc les les les
les les les les
parfeux les parfeux les les les
antichambres qui permettent de
cloisonner sont parfois extrêmement
rudimentaires sont souvent extrêmement
rudimenta merci monsieur nous allons
passer à des questions de collègue une
petite précision nous avons évidemment
été très intéressés par l'audition de
Monsieur Condamin cherpier que vous
apparemment vous avez rencontré depuis
euh on est un peu resté sur notre fin
est-ce qu'il vous a donné des précisions
sur les techniques des chif des noms euh
qu'il ne nous a pas donné à nous
éventuellement monsieur le Président
j'ai déjà répondu à cette question et je
le referai donc très
sincèrement le motif c'est une source
que j'ai fréquenté plusieurs fois fois
et le motif de la rencontre très
extensive et très précise du 29 mai
dernier à Genève où j'étais accompagné
par des confrères mais je leur laisse le
soin de de de le dire eux-même avaient
pour motif de le protéger finalement
première choses et donc avac comme
besoin qu'il nous dise le maximum de
choses et les plus précises possibles et
donc il nous a effectivement
donner un certain nombre une quinzaine
de noms de personnalités politiques par
exemple parce qu'il nous affirmait qu'il
avait été le témoin direct de
l'organisation de l'évasion fiscale de
ses personnalités au cours de toute sa
carrière pas seulement par UBS pas
seulement par la banque rail
principalement quand même par ces deux
banques il nous a donné de ce point de
vue-là bon des beaucoup de
d'informations très précises oui parfois
des montants les noms des banques
concernées les procédures utilisés les
motifs éventuels parce qu'ils sont
différents selon les personnes nous
avons eu ce genre de de de précision qui
pour tout vous dire n'était n'était
qu'une minuscule partie de de de
l'ensemble de ce qu'il nous a raconté je
je peux vous dire une chose c'est que le
Conseil lui a été donné et j'ai fait
partie de ceux qui lui ont donné ce
conseil qu'il réserve tout ça euh au
juges d'instruction qu'il l'aille parce
que nous avons je ne me sens pas en tant
que journaliste la capacité de vérifier
ce genre d'information même sur la base
de documents qu'il aurait pu me donner
euh je pense que on arrive dans des
choses tellement sensibles qui intéresse
tellement le public que seul un juge
d'instruction et des services de police
ont les moyens d'avoir des certitudes
dans la matière je crois savoir je sais
même que cette procédure
judiciaire aujourd'hui même a été mise
en mise en œuvre et je considère donc
qu'il y a un certain sérieux dans la
démarche de de cette source que je ne
connais pas absolument mais qui en tout
cas sur les choses que je connais et
notamment sur la banque UBS a toujours
été très précise parfaitement fiable et
et très certaine c'est très intéressant
ce que vous venez de nous dire est-ce
qu'il y a des des nom d'ancien ministre
et de ministre
actuel c'est c'est le cas monsieur le
Président c'est merercie
oui merci monsieur le Président oui
monsieur payon nous nous sommes donc
dans une deuxème série
d'auditions plus focalisé sur sur les
banques mais finalement on a un peu de
difficulté parce que le sujet est en
fait cyclique et on a du mal à à
s'arrêter uniquement aux
banques il se trouve que la semaine
prochaine nous avons un texte sur la
transparence de la vie publique pas
seulement de la vie politique mais de la
vie publique pour lequel la commission
des lois commence à travailler demain
certain nombre d'entre nous ont déjà
travaillé évidemment sur ce sujet et
puis la semaine d'après nous avons un
texte sur l'évasion fiscale et donc on
est dans le nogordien de nos affaires et
et le constat n'est plus suffisant
c'estàdire que là on a vraiment une
opportunité qui ne se reproduira pas
parce que ce texte est en en procédure
accélérée donc il y aura une lecture
dans chaque chambre donc moi j'ai envie
de vous demander d'abord quelques
préconisations claires sur lesquelles on
peut dans les semaines qui viennent
déposer des amendements pas dans 3 mois
pas dans 6 mois pas dans un an ça vient
après le 14 juillet donc là c'est tout
de suite alors on a évidemment quelques
idées liées évidemment au travail qu'on
a fait donc ça c'est la première chose
des choses claires et et et qui peuvent
être immédiatement transposable dans
notre droit positif la deuxième chose
c'est c'est un avis dans le cadre de la
précdente commission d'infraction enfin
sur l'évasion fiscale j'avais posé une
question un peu
iconoclaste
euh j'avais quand même le sentiment
qu'entre tracfine euh l'autorité
prudenti
et la commission d'infraction fiscale
qui est à berie non seulement ces gens
de coordonnait pas non seulement il
n'avait pas de retour de leur travail ni
d'évaluation mais plus grave c'est
qu'ils étaient parfaitement contents de
leur sort c'est-à-dire que chacun était
sauissonné dans sa tâche et trouvait ça
très bien chacun étant limité notamment
tracfine était très content même s'il y
avait pas de retour ils envoient des
déclarations de soupçon puis après
Vienne que pourra c'est pas grave bon
euh la commission d'infraction fiscale
contre lequel nous sommes un certain
nombre d'entre nous ici à avoir une
opinion pas forcément favorable quant à
son existence et sa survie donc-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez euh parce
que il y a il y a là une passoire et un
tri qui semble quand même tout à fait en
dehors du droit commun c'est-à-dire que
des gens passent et négocient dans le
cadre de cette commission qui évidemment
n'est pas saisi d'un certain nombre
d'arbitrage qui mériterait quand même
qu'on s'y intéresse donc tout ça pour
vous poser donc évidemment il y aurait
beaucoup d'autres questions la première
c'est comment comment coordonner le
système existant par exemple entre
l'autorité prudentielle que vous avez
cité comme ayant été défaillante le
texte à venir peut-il repousser et et et
améliorer son fonctionnement notamment
en instaurant des critères de temps et
euh pour les décisions et euh
et d'autres moyens de police si j'ose
dire la deuxième chose que pensez-vous
de la commission d'infraction
fiscale la troisème et celle que je vous
posais initialement est-ce que vous avez
quelques préconisations j'en aurais fini
pour en vous disant simplement que le
texte sur la transparence mais je
l'autre aussi prévoit une protection des
donneurs d'alerte et ça je crois que
c'est quand même une une très bonne
chose
l'article 16 l'article 17 l'article 17
comporte tout un tas de dispositions sur
la la protection du donneur d'alerte
donc je pense que ça vous vous pensez
que c'est une c'est une bonne idée qu'il
faut qu'il faut à mon sens
équilibrer parce que si le donneur
d'alerte doit être protégé en aucune
façon ça peut être un champ ouvert à la
délation donc il faut un équilibre qui
soit un
équilibre raisonnable
merci alors votre réponse monsieur payon
en particulier j'ai bien compris sur la
CF notamment oui mais pas seulement
peut-être
oui effectivement j'ai eu la chance de
de pouvoir participer d'assez près à
l'élaboration d'abord d'une proposition
de loi puisque au départ monsieur le
député Yan Galu était parti en dès le
dès le début janvier sur l'idée d'une
éventuelle proposition de loi il était
dans son groupe de travail mal nommé sur
les exilés fiscaux sur l'exil fiscal il
avait très vite compris qu'il s'agissait
plutôt d'évasion fiscale et et il
m'avait demandé est- ce que mes sources
ont accepté toutes mes sources les plus
importantes en France de il m'avait
demandé de de l'aider à trouver des
experts en la matière donc j'ai j'ai pu
voir l'élaboration de des différents
dispositifs et y compris ensuite du du
projet de
loi ce cette histoire du verrou de Bery
elle choque profondément elle choque
profondément l'une à l'unanimité tous
les experts avec lesquels je suis en
relation bien entendu première chose les
magistrats les premiers d'entre eux ce
sont les magistrats qui ne peuvent pas
comprendre qu'ils soit interdit parce
qu'ils le vivent comme ça d'enquêter y
compris quand ils ont un flagrant d'lit
de fraude fiscale y compris quand ce
flagrant d'lit de fraude fiscale porte
sur des dizaines voir des centaines de
millions
d'euros ils peuvent avoir connaissance
un procureur peut avoir connaissance un
juge d'instruction dans le cadre d'une
autre saisine des policiers de police
judiciaire et ils sont obligés de les
laisser passer et ils doivent attendre
que la Commission des infractions
financières fiscales donne soit son feu
vert mais plus que ça soit proactive sur
le
sujet en plus à
discrétion de la enfin la très haute
administration et et surtout du
gouvernement donc là il y a quelque
chose qui est une de laavis unanime des
magistrats de la vie unanime des
policiers de police judiciaire il y a là
aussi une aberration
euh ils ont il y a eu dans le cadre du
travail d'élaboration de la proposition
sol et surtout ensuite du projet de loi
il y a eu des discussions
interministérielles très importante très
chaude sur le sujet il y a un compromis
qui avait été construit entre le
ministère de la justice entre la la
garde des sauts et euh et Bercy je crois
qu'il y avait d'ailleurs des nuances
importantes entre les deux ministres le
ministre de l'Économie des Finances et
le ministre du Budget pour être clair je
pense que monsieur moscovissi était sur
une ligne qui était d'accepter un
certain compromis avec la justice sur un
système qui permettait à la fois de la à
la CF de continuer d'exister et de faire
son travail finalement fiscal parce que
c'est ça la motivation et à la justice
quand elle avait dans certaines
conditions et notamment des qure
flagrants d'élit qui pouvaient
motiver un procureur à saisir un juge
d'instruction ils le font en général pas
à tort et à travers et bien qu'il puisse
le faire et ce compromis a été défait
dans un arbitrage au plus haut niveau
disons 3 semaines avant que le projet de
loi arrive à l'Assemblée nationale ça a
été un choc je peux vous le dire j'en ai
été le témoin ça a été un véritable choc
dans la magistrature ça a été un choc je
pense chez vos confrères et cons sœurs
de l'Assemblée nationale qui sont
sincères dans le le motif de construire
une loi qui soit efficace puis ça a été
un choc voilà chez les policiers et
cetera c'est quelque chose qui
qui a des conséquences je pense
fantastiques négativement fantastiqu il
n'y aura pas réellement de répression de
la fraude fiscale s'il n'y a pas la
possibilité pour la justice d'agir la
seule chose que craint le fraudeur c'est
pas la rectification fiscale d'autant
qu'elle se négocie vous le savez bien à
très très bas
taux je pense que on est même parfois on
est à peu près l'ordre du taux de
l'amende du BS France c'est le pourcent
c'est on est à des taux qui sont
ridiculement bas qui sont bien plus bas
que le taux de l'impôt tout simplement
quand il y a rectification souvent et et
il y a surtout aucune opprobe d'aucune
sorte ce que c le fraudeur c'est bien
plus le juge d'instruction c'est la
condamnation au tribunal quand bien même
d'ailleurs cette condamnation n'est pas
forcément mortel mais voilà on redevient
citoyen on est exposé au regard des
autres citoyens je crois que le fait que
la justice n'ait aucun mot à dire sur la
fraude fiscale en tant que délit est
quelque chose de de totalement aberrant
il y a un deuxième gros verrou qui est
d'ailleurs peut-être un peu lié quelque
part parce que ça concerne la police
judiciaire et ça concerne les juges
d'instruction et ça concerne les
procureurs comment se fait-il qu'une
police et pas seulement une police
comment se fait-il que le renseignement
qui sait tout je je peux vous le dire
c'est tout très tôt très en amont y
compris le renseignement militaire qui
s'intéresse énormément et à juste titre
à tous les aspects financiers et et y
compris aux aspects de fraude enfin en
tout cas de de de dissimulation des
avoirs financiers comment se fait-il que
des fonctionnaires qui ont connaissance
très en amont des fraudes ne se
soumettent jamais à l'article 40 du Code
pénal de procédure pénale ne signale
jamais
un
procureur des faits délicteux qui n'ont
rien à voir avec ce qui peut-être et
doit être couvert par le secret défense
voilà il le dénonc eux-mêmes j'ai pris
le risque d'être en relation avec des
officiers du renseignement intérieur qui
me l'ont dit me l'ont affirmé
considèrent que ça n'est pas normal que
c'est un scandale qui ont même fait un
document écrit en la matière sur ce
sujet concernant UBS précisé
qui avait été transmis à l'Assemblée
nationale ils sont la la catégorique et
j'ai vu que d'autres experts le disent
des experts du métier des commissaires
de police des gens qui ont couvert des
affaires d'état très très importantes et
qui disent il n'y a aucune justification
pas même celle qui est la plus
importante celle du renseignement pour
que nous
réservions sous le saut du secret
défense des informations que nous
récoltons sur des
fraudes notamment fiscal dont nous
sommes les premiers connaisseurs dont
nous sommes les premiers témoins et qui
euh nécessiteraiit un travail judiciaire
donc là il y a aussi une sorte de verrou
euh sur euh comment le renseignement se
soustrait à l'article 40 du code de
procédure pénale il y a un troisième
dans la la question des
amendements il y a quelque chose qui est
porté par les douaniers les policiers et
qui me semble assez légitime même si
certains y ont vu une atteinte
potentielle à la liberté de faire
circuler l'arrê la caisse quand on est
commerçant tous disent quand 10000 € de
liquide circule il y a besoin pour les
services judiciaires de simplement
pouvoir demander quelle est
l'origine de ces fonds en liquide passer
les sommes de 10000 € alors on leur rép
rpondu c'était à l'Assemblée nationale
que 10000 € bah c'était la caisse de
l'épicerie et que exposer l'épicière qui
porte ses 10000 € à la banque de à une
éventuelle une
éventuelle un éventuel contrôle pour que
elle puisse répondre à la question mais
d'où vous viennent ces 10000 € et
qu'elle elle est à perdre du temps à
dire j'ai vendu des carambars des
carottes et et des choux je pense que ça
n'est pas sérieux je je prends très au
sérieux
l'expérience de policiers et de
douaniers parfaitement républicains
parfaitement respectueux des libertés
publiques et qui disent pour nous ça
serait un outil extraordinaire de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale notamment
internationale de pouvoir demander
quelle est l'origine de fonds en liquide
à partir d'une certaine somme c'est
valable sur l'or vous le savez la
circulation de l'or est soustrait
totalement quel que soit sa quantité son
montant
à des à des perquisitions à des
interrogations judiciaires il y a
quelque chose là qui est abérant donc il
y a là des amendements qui sont portés
et qui était dans le cadre déjà du
travail fait à l'Assemblée nationale qui
me semble méritait une certaine
attention euh de la part des
parlementaires en général et puis pour
finir les lanceurs d'alertes je crois
que le dispositif là qui a été proposé
est bon il est satisfaisant au regard
des experts que je connais et des
lanceurs d'alerte
d'alerte puisque ils vont enfin voir ce
statut qui était tout simplement mes
sources qui ont pris tous les risques je
dirais juste une petite chose il faut
bien entendu l'équilibre qui fait que il
y a pas de dénonciation gratuite et je
crois que là en la matière c'est pas
difficile de trouver les les bon les
bonnes disposition je dirais que dans
certains cas quand des lanceurs d'alerte
le font totalement gratuitement et pour
des motifs qui sont des motifs moraux
voire des motifs civiques parce que j'ai
beaucoup rencontré ça il y aurait et
c'est pas forcément pécunière il serait
peut-être pas mal de prévoir une
reconnaissance de la République ils y
sont tous très sensibles je peux vous
dire que l'Ordre National du Mérite j'en
ai entendu parler à titre fantasmatique
pour ces malheureux lanceurs d'alertees
mais eux quand ils font ce qu'ils font à
leurs risques et périls et ils sont
parfois considérables et bien notre
drapeau le blanc-rouge euh notre devise
républicaine la médaille euh la médaille
de guerre du grand-père ou de la
grand-mère des souvenirs de ce qu'ils
ont appris à l'école en instruction
civique ça n'est pas de la blague ça je
peux vous le dire j'en ai été très
impressionné et que ce soit dans les
sources du secteur privé et que ce soit
dans les sources évidemment du secteur
public les fonctionnaires donc il y a ça
dernier point il y a les repentis la
question des repentis qui est une
question difficile d'autres pays que le
nôtre ont une pratique alors sur des
affaires certes criminelles mais les
experts en matière de Tra très grande
fraude fiscale vous expliqueront que ça
a souvent lien avec les affaires
criminelles quid de celui qui ou de
celle qui a fauté parce que c'était le
système parce que c'était une autre
époque les années 2000 c'est pas les
années
2010 en enjeu y compris en enjeu pour la
société et je sais qu'il y a un certain
nombre de banquiers qui ont fait ces
choseslà et qui aujourd'hui sont
déterminés à dire la vérité bon vous en
avez auditionné un je sa pas à quel
degré ça sera pas à moi de le dire il a
participé au système mais il prend des
risques il y en a un autre et c'est
passé très inaperçu c'était dommage le
journal Le Temps ma consœur
correspondante du temps ici à Paris
Catherine duboulose a publié les
confessions c'est le titre de son
article d'un banquier suisse en
Suisse qui raconte dans le détail
comment il opérait sur le territoire
français
B la récolte de l'évasion fiscale c'est
un témoignage qui à mon avis est aussi
extraordinaire que celui de Pierre
Condamin Gerbier mais aux risques et
périles alors là c'est un Suisse au
risques et péril de cette personne mais
nous avons en France et je le sais je
suis bien placé pour le savoir des
potentialités d'aveux ou de confession
de gens qui n'ont pas fait si plus grave
que d'exécuter des ordre et qui dans des
conditions d'un dispositif repenti
porterait beaucoup à la à la justice
alors je soumets ça à votre à votre
réflexion merci Monsieur avant que
peut-être une petite précision soit
demandée tout à l'heure je vais passer
la parole à Madame bouchou qui a une
question à vous poser puis après à notre
collègue Chiron et après si la réponse
n'est pas apporté à la petite question
dernière petite question madame Goulet
on lui redonnera la parole euh monsieur
payant merci de revenir pour la la
saison 2 de notre mission moi j'ai une
question extrêmement terre à terre à
vous poser vous l'avez dit y a un
instant en fait on a changé d'époque euh
ce qui a ce qu'il y a 20 ans était un
usage qui allait de perd avec une
certaine réussite je mets des guillemet
qui souvent se conjuguait avec de
l'évasion et un compte à l'étranger est
devenu problématique plus problématique
il y a une dizaine d'années et de nos
jours est devenu un problème majeur
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que pour
aider à tourner une page ce serait le
plus simple serait que collectivement
cette dizaine ou quinzaine de personnes
que vous avez potentiellement évoqué
tout à l'heure fasse un coming out et
reconnaissent que les temps ont changé
et que de aille de paère entre on va
dire euh euh une une prise de parole
publique de ces banquiers de ces
magistrats qui se plaignent beaucoup du
système de ces policiers qu'il y ait
aussi je pense à ces sportifs de haut
niveau à ces politiques il faut appeler
un Chatchat qui puisse peut-être
reconnaître que le le vent a tourné et
que il faut faire quelque chose que
pensez-vous de cette idée
écoutez moralement je me sens proche de
de de votre proposition après faut
regarder les choses comme elles sont les
personnes qui font ça elles sont dans
une gestion très très rationnelle de
leurs
intérêts et très franchement
aujourd'hui ça serait tout
perdre pour rien pour rien ou presque
rien pas même la reconnaissance de qui
que ce soit et et et je vous le redis
j'ai vraiment le sentiment mais je crois
que la preuve commence d'en être apporté
que même quand on n même quand on fait
ses aveux
euh bien orchestré médiatiquement avant
d'entrer dans un cabinet d'un juge
d'instruction
euh on ne paye
rien et je crois que le seul vrai motif
malheureusement nous sommes pas encore
au 7e millénaire le seul vrai motif qui
font qui fera que des fraudeurs
avoueront le leur fraude c'est qu' ils
paieront moins en en avouant que ils ne
paieront si ils n'ont pas avoué c'est
tout je suis désolé mais je crois qu'en
la matière c'est pas mon tempérament
croyez-le mais je crois que le
bâton c'est important on a besoin d'un
d'un système judiciaire fort l'État doit
être fort il faut pas je rêve comme je
crois beaucoup d'autres qu'un jour nous
n'aurons pas besoin de l'autorité
publique au sens de la répression et que
seulle l'éducation suffira nous n'y
sommes pas tout à fait encore et donc
nous avons besoin d'un État fort et
d'une d'un système judiciaire
parce qu'il est aujourd'hui tellement
faible ça en revanche je l'ai constaté
que tous les autres forts et ils sont
parfois pas si fort que ça règne en
maître règne en maître voilà les juges
ils en rigolent je vais vous dire une
chose je suis informé quasiment
quotidiennement de ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de la banque UBS France
voilà au plus haut niveau des gens qui
sont tout proches du
président depuis que j'ai publié ce
livre il est arrivé il a été nommé
président de cette banque juste après la
publication de mon livre c'est un un
cadeau je suis pas tout à fait sûr que
ce soit complètement un hasard il rigole
en
permanence je prends le risque de dire
que je pense qu'il se moque du
monde je pense que toutes ces
déclarations y compris les plus récentes
sont des pieds de nez à la justice à
l'information quand elle est bonne et
souvent aujourd'hui je trouve que les
médias font bien leur boulot de nombreux
titres de presse et de de l' visuel tout
ça il s'en moque il payent des fortunes
des cabinets d'avocats des cabinets
d'enquête
privée des conseillers
américains et il bâtit des grandes
stratégies de communication dont il
pense que rien ne leur résistera ni les
petits juges ni les petits journalistes
ni voilà c'est ça la mentalité quand
même du monde à la fois des fraudeurs et
de ceux qui les servent
merci Monsieur
Chiron oui monsieur monsieur Pillon je
voudrais justement évoquer cette
fonction à la fois de journaliste et de
et de l'opinion publique lorsqu'on avait
été à Bruxelles ensemble on avait évoqué
devant devant des personnes de la
Commission de Bruxelles la possibilité
de faire de la communication vis-à-vis
de l'opinion publique moi j'ai été assez
frappé en Belgique quand de certains
quand en Suisse que quand l'opinion
publique comprend que elle est elle
imposée fiscalement normalement et que
ce qui fraudent viennent se réfugier
chez elles et sont imposés
anormalement et donc dans le budget de
de ces états en Belgique c'est
pratiquement fini en partie je diraisin
qu'en Suisse on voit que des canton vote
en disant non suffit hein on refuse ce
type de situation et donc ce que je
voulais dire c'est en tant que
journaliste en tant qu'opinion publique
je pense qu'il a un rôle très important
et vous le faites donc je tenais à le à
le saluer deuxièmement toute autre chose
par rapport au très grands groupes
euh on l'a on l'a évoqué ici c'est quand
même le découplage entre ce qu'on dirait
le le entre le le lien réel de
l'économie c'està-dire là où on paye les
salaires où on tire les profits où on a
des revenus bon et puis le les lieux
juridiques hein où se passe hein où la
la société et donc à un moment donné est
ce que les États dans dans leur ensemble
vont vont se rendre compte que ce
découplage il n'est il n'est pas
acceptable parce qu'à ce moment-là
peut-être qu'on aura
réglé cette espèce de de de de de fraude
que l'on voit je parle là plutôt sur les
grands groupes que sur les individus
hein c'est tout autre chose et ça ça
c'est le véritable
pouvoir aussi parce qu'on a des
financiers on a pas des industriels
monsieur le sénateur merci pour d'une
part votre premier propos sur le le rôle
bien sûr de de ceux qui socialement ont
comme métier de de faire connaître au
public les les réalités tant qu'ils
peuvent de du fonctionnement de la
société je mettrais juste un un petit
point de nuance il me semble qu'en
Suisse l'opinion publique majoritaire
très largement majoritaire est encore
défavorable à ce que il n'y ait pas la
pratique de la protection des avoirs des
des citoyens des autres pays donc ça ça
ça c'estz limite je pense qu'en revanche
en France je vois bien que la la
pédagogie et la la l'information y
compris quand elle est un peu complexe
finalement est bien comprise du public
et c'est encore une bonne leçon pour
nous sur le la capacité d'intelligence
du public quand on lui dit les choses
comme elles sont sur le deuxème point
c'est assez récemment que je me suis
intéressé monsieur le rapporteur je
crois vous le savez à la question des
des entreprises j'étis effaré de ce que
j'ai entendu c'est-à-dire que la
pratique systématique et ceux qui ne le
font pas sont d'ailleurs au rangcart ou
sont marginaux la pratique systématique
c'est de créer des structures offshore
des sociétés écran notamment à
Luxembourg pour le milieu économique
c'est vraiment Luxembourg de sorte à
récolter les royalties parce que de plus
en plus notre économie est non pas sur
les matériaux non pas sur les
marchandises mais sur les brevets sur
tout ce qui est en fait euh voà le le
copyright et de récolter y compris pour
les groupes de presse c'est devenu une
pratique visiblement
importante des groupes de presse d'une
certaine importance et bien on crée ces
structures offshore de façon à
récolter les les royalties sans avoir à
déclarer quoi que ce soit au fisque de
son pays euh c'est devenu tellement
systématique que aujourd'hui on voit
bien que les États
on les États et puis les élus locaux
parce que finalement ça les touche euh
ont quelques réticences à contraindre
certains grands groupes et souvent nos
entreprises aujourd'hui sont un peu
mondialisées même des même des grosses
PME par exemple comme mon groupe à moi
groses PME mais on a des activités en
Asie et cetera ils ont des du mal à les
à les contraindre à payer l'impôt comme
il devrait le faire parce qu'il y a le
chantage à l'emploi tout simplement et
qu'on échange de cette capacité de
doubler son résultat parce que ça permet
de doubler son résultat financier et
bien il y a le fait que on accepte
d'avoir encore des salariés euh sur le
territoire français ou le territoire
bourguignon je pense que dans un
reportage diffusé par France 2 encore
une fois il y a pas très longtemps euh
il était très clair que un grand groupe
de distribution de produits culturels
mondial ayant une implantation en
Bourgogne
bénéficier à la fois de
subvention du salut bien entendu de la
grande personnalité politique à qui je
n'ai aucun reproche à faire hein euh qui
voilà avait organisé la chose et que par
par ailleurs ben l'impôt c'était tout à
fait accessoire voilà là encore comme la
réponse tout à l'heure je pense qu'on ne
peut pas être naïf et et ne pas voir
qu'il y a un rapport de force
aujourd'hui très très défavorable de
toute la puissance publique vis-à-vis de
pouvoir de puissance publique de
puissance privé qui sont pas toujours
des grands groupes internationaux mais
qui aujourd'hui font la loi parce que
tout simplement c'est eux qui créent des
emplois ou qui défond des emplois c'est
ce que je constate partout en tout cas
une chose que je peux vous assurer
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il est devenu la
normalité économique et d'avoir entre
autres des structures offshore non
déclarées notre rapporteur va reprendre
la
discussion oui je voudrais revenir sur
un un élément qu'on a évoqué tout à
l'heure dans cette contribution à la
prise de conscience générale l'enquête
offshorex du mois d'avril qui de mon
point de vue a été enfin était un
travail de qualité qui porté sur
plusieurs mois qui a impliqué des
dizaines d'organes de presse de par le
monde des dizaines de journalistes
compétents publication sur trois journé
y compris publication de noms et des
noms ont été cités dans l'enquête en
question de français de personnalités
françaises et étrangères et depuis j'ai
constaté que le le l'organe de presse
français qui avait contribué à cette
enquête s'était désolidarisé de la
publication des fichiers à un moment
donné et puis depuis en gros plus rien
silence un peu et je suis un peu
interpellé par ce silence après le grand
bruit que cette enquête de qualité
encore une fois a pu faire est-ce que
vous avez un commentaire une
interprétation là-dessus ou pas oui
monsieur le rapporteur j'ai j'ai connu
l'existence de cette enquête avant
qu'elle elle soit publiée par des
confrères suisses qui participaient au
au dispositif et j'ai connu les données
précises qu'ils avaient notamment sur
Singapour sur des sociéés été écran créé
par des banques qui m'intéressent don
dont UBS à Singapour et donc j'ai vu à
la fois la qualité des données
récoltées tous les noms en gros de
c'était très systématique tous les noms
des sociétés écran offshore créé pour
gérer en seconde main des comptes
bancaires donc avec anonymisation des
ayants droit premier mais j'ai vu en
même temps le défaut de ces données
c'est que ce n'était que des noms de
société
écran éventuellement avec leur gérant
officiel mais aucune donnée précise sur
ce qui est en aval qui est plus
intéressant les comptes
bancaires combien avec quel mouvement
pour qui qui est
l'ayantroit premier le véritable
bénéficiaire de ces structures voilà il
manquait tout ça y compris avec un
manque fondamental qui était
l'évaluation de l'aspect illégal ou non
de ces structures juridiques certes
moralement qui pouvait nous interroger
mais qui pouvait tout à fait être légal
vous le savez un nom a été cité par le
journal Le Monde puisque c'était bien
nos confrères du monde le nom de
Monsieur haudier proche du président de
la République
actuelle sans qu'il y ait eu la moindre
capacité du journal de nous éclairer sur
le fait que c'est mon c'est ces sociétés
étaient légales ou illégales quelles
étaient les mouvements financiers
qu'elles avaient abrités ou non voilà je
je me suis interrogé en tant que
journaliste et je l'ai dit sur une
antenne de radio publique je n'aurais
pas personnellement publié comme ils
l'ont fait cette cet état de l'enquête
ce qui me paraissait être plutôt un
commencement de l'enquête je n'ai pas
bien compris la finalité la preuve en
est et vous l'avez dit vous-même
qu'est-ce que ça a produit d'autrre
qu'une sorte de bruit de fond sur le
sujet global du offshore mais sans
données précises des noms finalement
beaucoup moins qu'à la limite mon
modeste petit livre en a
produit avec ses petites listes à lui
notamment dans le monde du football
professionnel et du
showbsiness après je suis en relation
avec des sources des sources judiciaires
et des sources du renseignement je sais
quex s'interroge beaucoup sur une sorte
de grande man poulation de l'opinion
publique notamment
européenne d'origine anglo-saxonne pour
à la fois nous faire peur pour dire
regardez finalement on a tout publié il
y a plus rien à voir de nombreux motifs
psychosociaux disons qui font partie
éventuellement de la guerre économique
de la guerre économique qu'il y a entre
le monde anglo-saxon et le vieux monde
européen moi je on peut décrypter ça je
crois que certains certaines personnes
du renseignement européen décrypte les
choses comme ça après moi j'ai pas la
compétence suffisante pour être certain
qu'ils ont raison ou tort mais voilà en
tout cas d'un point de vue
journalistique euh je n'aurais rien fait
de la même façon je n'aurais pas fait de
la même façon pour autant je hein ce
n'est pas mes consœurs et confrères qui
l'ont fait voilà je ils font bien leur
boulot hein euh dernière question
concernant le le les sources que vous
avez cité au niveau du du renseignement
des services d'enquête et j'ai en tête
la la démarche dont il a été question
dans la presse de la DCRI il y a
quelques semaines ou mois qui ont remis
je crois une note un document à nos
collègues députés à l'Assemblée
nationale en gros ça faisait un peu état
de leur difficulté à exercer leur
mission si j'ai bonne mémoire euh
qu'est-ce qu'il est devenu de cette
remise de document qu'est-ce qu' est-ce
que cette note disait euh voilà est-ce
qu'il est-ce qu'on nous explique les
difficultés réell organisé ou pas de de
leur façon de fonctionner toujours avec
le souci de d'arriver à la transparence
la viérité la lumière est-ce que vous
avez des éléments là-dessus oui bien sûr
les deux parce que j'avais connaissan
très précis j'ai d'ailleurs publié dans
La Croix un article assez modeste mais
substantiel sur le sujet il y avait deux
grands axes d'abord c'était une note
double il y a une note d'analyse de tous
les service de police et de le leur
manque d'articulation et de moyens sur
la répression de la fraude fiscale en
général donc ça débordait largement la
question du renseignement puis il y
avait une note particulière très brève
très très très très dense sur le fiasco
qu'on peut appeler ça comme ça ou le
défaut d'action judiciaire sur la
question du BS alors que il disait ses
officiers que ils avaient eu
connaissance eux-mêmes très très tôt de
de des délits et il se plaignait primo
que on les empêche sous prétexte de
secret défense de transmettre au
judiciaire de d'activer l'article 40 il
n'envoit pas le motif ce sont des
officiers de renseignement hein c'est
pas des des policiers de police
judiciaire même si dans leur carrière
certains ont pu avoir des carrières
judiciaires mais donc il disait qu'il
n'y a pas de motif sérieux de les
couvrir sur ces faits-là par le secret
défense ils sont nusque et la deuxième
chose c'est qu'ils disent ils affirment
qu'il y avait pour ça des motifs le fait
qu'on les empêche de transmettre au
judiciaire voire de continuer d'enquêter
il y avait des motifs politiques il y
avait des motifs dont je vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure de protection de certains
clans politiques ils l'écrivent noir sur
blanc vous imaginez bien que ça a fait
scandale notamment à l'Assemblée
nationale je pense que certains députés
qui sont en protection de nos
institutions policières sont monté au
créneau pour dire que j'avais été
moi-même l'auteur de cette note que elle
était le fait d'un fantaisiste que bon
tout ça a fait que on commençait même
dans un certain journal à désigner des
sources précisément presque
personnellement et bien ces officiers
ont décidé que ça devait arriver aussi
là dans les sur le bureau des juges
d'instruction et je crois çair je sais
que la fameuse note est
a été saisie été reçu par deux juges
d'instruction que elle les a beaucoup
intéressé et que les sources policières
qui les portaient ont été vues au moins
deux fois par les 10 juges
d'instructionènellement
oui je je suis désolée de de revenir
mais je c'est vrai que le sujet
tellement vaste et en même
temps à bissal on n pas on n' pas fini
de poser des questions je voulais
simplement vous demander votre
avis modestement j'ai déposé un
amendement pour que la Haute Autorité de
transparence puisse avoir des liens
institutionnels avec tracfine
pensez-vous que ce soit une bonne
idée ce que je sais de alors je sais pas
si c'est une bonne idée je je pense pas
avoir la capacité de vous répondre
malheureusement là-dessus je peux vous
répondre par un biais quand même c'est
que je je sais je crois savoir que cette
organisation Tracfin a connaissance
d'énormément de de données très précises
que les remontées d'informations qui
viennent des banques sont considérables
et en quantité et en qualité et que là
encore se pose la même problématique de
comment de cette institution il y a
passage éventuel au judicièire euh il y
a déjà passage au fisque mais je pense
qu'entre Bery et Tracfin les les choses
circulent c'est bien euh après elle
circule déjà beaucoup moins bien quand
ça peut avoir des conséquences d'ordre
judiciaire et il y a là encore une des
pratiques très discrétionnaires parce
que sur un cas précis et
récent je sais que des informations
avaient été récoltées elles sont elles
étaient de très grande qualité elles ont
été conservées par la direction de de
Tracfin euh et puis finalement je ne
sais pas si elles ont été exploitées
junicièrement alors qu'elles auraient a
pu l'être merci là il y a un outil qui
est effectivement très efficace et
sous-exploité merci beaucoup votre
audition démontre effectivement que les
choses évoluent puisque par rapport à
votre audition lors de la dernière
commission vous avez apporté des
informations complémentair
euh riche et différente de celle que
vous nous avez donné la dernière fois
euh sous réserve si vous en êtes
d'accord que vous donniez à la
commission vos dernières expériences sur
le dernier état de
l'ingénierie de l'optimisation fiscale
et c'est-à-dire des
techniques je voudrais vous poser une
question un peu plus qui m'est venue à
l'esprit à l'occasion des différentes
auditions on parle on parle beaucoup de
l'Europe du Luxembourg de la
Suisse de Londres dans certaines
auditions des îles caillïan nous parlons
du de la Ware et autres
mais est-ce que l'évasion fiscale la
fraude fiscale est-ce que c'est vraiment
une invention occidentale est-ce qu'on a
l'assurance que la Russie la Chine les
États du Moyen-Orient sont des état
coopératif monsieur le Président nous
avons l'assurance qu'ils ne le sont pas
euh
ou ils le sont comme ils veulent euh il
faudrait ajouter Hong Kong qui est
devenue une place dont on entend
maintenant toujours parler parce qu'elle
est particulièrement opaque résistante à
toute toute enquête judiciaire voilà
c'est c'est ce que ça ça ça ça revient
un peu à ce que on se disait tout à
l'heure à propos du de l'aspect
maintenant systématique quasiment normal
de notre système économique l'évasion
fiscale étant un outil devenu normal de
notre système économique et on voit bien
que les pays émergents et compris
certaines grandes puissances et vous
avez cité la Russie et moi j'entends
beaucoup parler chez les
magistrats dans cette articulation
terrible entre la criminalité organisée
et la fraude fiscale bah oui de ces
pays-là qui font ce qu'ils veulent comme
ils veulent mais quand même avec
toujours quelque part le besoin de
l'outil Suisse parce que c'est une place
centrale parce que il y a une sorte de
blanchiment
d'honorabilité parce que pour certaines
affaires qui vont être à l'intersection
des affaires procheorientales et des
affaires de l'Est et bien il y a là une
opportunité
géographique une
dimension que j'ai vu constante le
besoin pour les gens qui sont les grands
décideurs de notre monde
d'avoir du luxe d'être dans des
contextes de club
flatteurs on ne va pas faire des
affaires au bistr du coin on souhaite
des fauteuils en cuir dans des grands
halls de grands hôtels si possible dans
des nations qui ont suffisamment
d'ancienneté pour que
l'anoblissement parce que il y a ça
cette dimension là l'anoblissement que
représente le fait de fréquenter ses
grands hôtels voilà favorise la qualité
des relations avec les autres hommes
d'affaires et la Suisse je peux vous
dire quand on va à Genève ou les grands
hôtels le bord du lac ça reste encore un
motif dans UBS et je conclus
complètement là-dessus ce que j'ai vu
dans le motif des fraudeurs la dimension
club et mes confrère de mediaap part
dans la série qu'ils ont faite sur UBS
là tout récemment l'ont très bien
démontré par les photos publiées par les
listes partout tous les documents qu'il
ont montré la dimension
mondaine de cette activité est un motif
sociologique fort on est dans une
certaine
société donc oui les pays que vous avez
cité certainement mais avec le besoin et
bien du décorum de la Suisse du
Luxembourg de quelques grands hôtels ou
grandes banque française parce que tout
ça quelque part représente de la
sécurité et puis aussi de l'honorabilité
à leurs
yeux merci
beaucoup merci merci beaucoup
intéressant très alors tout d'abord
monsieur avant de de de vous faire
prêter serment je voudrais vous
remercier ainsi que votre confrère et
plinel des mots fondés fondés mais
agréabl qui que vous avez écrit dans un
récent ouvrage sur le rapport sur
l'évasion fiscale qui avait été mené par
le Sénat dont le rapporteur est à ma est
à ma gauche que beaucoup d'entre nous
ici ont voté quand tout hypothèse tous
ceux qui faisaient partie de la
commission sur préalable à ce rapport
ont voté à
l'unanimité alors je crois que ces mots
agréables m'autorise tout de même à
faire un petit peu une observation sur
un certain passage de votre ouvrage qui
me paraît pouvoir jeter le le troup vous
avez affirmé que le journalisme devait
éviter d'être un journalisme d'opinion
encore plus un journalisme de
complaisance frôlant le publ
reportage même si je pense qu'on doit
reconnaître au journalisme d'opinion
sous réserve qu'il annonce ce qu'il est
une forme de
légitimité nous pouvons partager cette
affirmation en tout cas considérer
qu'une forme de rééquilibrage devrait
devrait intervenir nous avons d'ailleurs
pu expérimenter la semaine dernière les
excès d'un certain journalisme
spectacle en revanche il me semble que
lorsque vous écrivez dans l'ouvrage sur
l'affaire Cusac le mensonge de Monsieur
CUS je vous cite fut accompagné
cautionné entretenu par la majorité de
la classe politique vous allez peut-être
un peu au-delà du journalisme euh euh de
fait je pense que cette affirmation
procède d'une peut-être d'une certaine
méconnaissance de la classe politique et
peut-être aussi des réalités
institutionnelles parce que je dois vous
dire que vous trouverez sans doute assez
peu de sénateurs euh qui puissent
relever de ce jugement un peu vous le
reconnaîtrez euh amalgamant que vous
avez que vous avez énoncé là je
m'empresse de dire que que cette
affirmation notamment rien euh la
considération que nous inspire votre
travail d'enquête d'autant qu'il est
très exact qu'en ce domaine on se sent
quelquefois très
seul et nous pourrons donc revenir
utilement sur cette dimension de
solitude entre nous d'autant qu'elle
entre dans les préoccupations de la
commission d'enquête comme vous le savez
nous nous intéressons en effet au
contrôle des faits de soustraction de
richesse soit dans l'utilisation d'une
ingénierie légale de la concurrence cal
soit dans les pratiques frauduleuses et
puis bien sûr dans l'environnement
culturel du contrôle qui est selon toute
apparence sûrement un un vrai problème
voilà je voulais donc vous dire que nous
étions satisfaits de voir que notre
travail avait été lu et apprécié et
apportter cette petite précision dont
vous jugerez vous-même qu'elle était
empreinte de politesse
euh sur ce fait je vais maintenant vous
demander de prêter serment monsieur
Fabrice Harfi prêtez-vous serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
levez la main droite et dites je le jure
je le jure merci beaucoup donc nous
allons procéder comme nous procédons
habituellement par un exposé j'allais
dire une figure libre vous nous
indiquerez tout ce que vous souhaitez
révéler réaffirmer à notre commission
sur le thème de notre commission après
quoi éc boet notre rapporteur vous
posera un certain nombre de questions
qui seront vraisemblablement développées
par
euh par mes collègues alors écoutez
monsieurs vous avez la
parole merci de d'abord de l'invitation
car c'est toujours un moment
démocratique important quand le
Parlement se saisit de ces pouvoirs
d'investigation alors pour rebondir sur
ce que vous venez de dire sur le
journalisme
d'opinion la position qui qui est la
même qui est la mienne n'est pas de dire
dire qu'il y aurait un journalisme
supérieur à un autre mais simplement que
de mon point de vue je pense que ce ne
sont pas les opinions qui font l'opinion
mais les faits qui font l'opinion et
c'est pour ça que j'aime être un artisan
de l'information par les faits c'est ce
que je vais tenter ici le plus
modestement possible si tentz que ça
puisse éclairer les travaux de la
commission de montrer par les faits par
les documents par ce que nous avons
révélé dans miaapart car je vient ici un
peu comme un porte-parole des enquêtes
de Médiapart depuis depuis 5 ans il est
vrai que depuis que le journal a été
lancé en mars 2008 nous avons eu à
mettre au jour un certain nombre
d'histoires qui sont devenus des
affaires et qui sont aujourd'hui des
dossiers judiciaires c'est ainsi je peux
parler de l'affaire tapis de l'affaire
takedine de l'affaire béancour de
l'affaire karashi de l'affaire kusac de
l'affaire Kaddafi il se trouve que
toutes ces affaires il y a comme le
disait Claude levistros un invariant
dans toutes ces affaires et c'est
précisément ce qui nous nous anime et
nous rejoint ici sont les paradis
fiscaux dans toutes les affaires que je
viens de citer il y a les paradis
fiscaux en permanence partout tout le
temps pour plusieurs raisons vous le
savez bien mieux que moi le paradis
fiscal permet de évidemment contourner
l'impôt avec une obsession qui pour
certains relève de la jouissance mais
pas seulement le paradis fiscal est une
boîte noire qui permet de cacher
l'argent qui permet de cacher l'argent
quand son origine n'est pas avouable ou
et ou quand sa destination ne l'est pas
non plus donc c'est aussi une boîte
noire de la corruption une boîte noire
du blanchiment une boîte noire de toutes
les pratiques financières illicites qui
font que l'enrichissement de
quelques-uns correspond en réalité à la
à l'appauvrissement de tous c'est de de
cela dont nous parlons cet argent que
nous nous nous devons les uns les uns
les autres alors dans dans dans toutes
ces ces affaires le paradis fiscal est
est constant et c'est vrai que pour nous
journalistes il est parfois compliqué
une fois d'avoir révéler les fait
parfois avec le caractère spectaculaire
qu'ils peuvent recouvrir ou l'aspect un
peu sulfureux de tel ou tel personnalité
qui est désignée dans telle ou telle
enquête qui provoque ce qu'on peut
appeler parfois le scandale ou la
polémique ce avec quoi je n'ai aucune
difficulté mais il y a un deuxième étage
de la fusée qui pour nous est toujours
compliqué je trouve c'est la pédagogie
de tout cela car si les affaires que
nous révélons devaient rester des sortes
de faits divers financier un peu
spectaculaire j'estime que nous aurions
perdu la bataille de l'information et le
plus dur et le travail des commissions
d'enquête parlementair le travail des
hommes politiques le travail des
institutions le travail de la presse est
aussi de faire la pédagogie pourquoi
tout cela a du sens pourquoi tout cela a
du sens et c'est pourquoi je me permets
de venir avec une toute petite citation
d'un d'un ouvrage que peut-être vous
connaissez qui est sobrement intitulé
les paradis fiscaux qui est sorti en
2012 aux éditions André Versailles de
mon confrère américain Nicolas shacson
qui est journaliste pour entre autres Z
économist ou le le le Financial Times
qui sont pas réputés he pour êt des
journaux révolutionnaires et pourtant ce
que nous dit Nicolas shakson de ses
enquêtes sur les paradis fiscaux paradis
fiscaux c'est que ils ne sont pas
contrairement à ce qu'on peut entendre
ici ou là une économie parallèle mais un
réel poumon ils sont au cœur de
l'économie mondiale et il a une
définition qui très imagée qui nous
permet je crois à tous de comprendre de
quoi nous parlons et pourquoi ce ne sont
pas simplement des affaires qui flottent
comme ça au-dessus de nos têtes et ne
nous concernerai pas au quotidien il a
cette cette image que je me permets de
de vous lire imaginez-vous dans un
supermarché où vous faites vos courses
tous les jours derrière un cordon de de
velour rouge pardon des personnes bien
habillées règlent leurs achats à une
caisse prioritaire sur votre ticket de
caisse il y a une ligne frais divivers
avec en face une somme énorme destinée à
financer les aats les achats des
personnes derrière le cordon rouge
désolé vous dit le gérant d'un
supermarché on n' pas le choix si vous
ne payez pas la moitié de leurs achats
ils iront faire leur course ailleurs
veuillez régler s'il vous plaît voilà ce
qu'il se passe concrètement si nous
appliquons le principe du paradis fiscal
à la vie courante nous payons pour
d'autres bon alors je je suis venu avec
des exemples pour ne pas faire de
discours parce que je n'en ai ni les
moyens voilà intellectuels ni la
prétention mais simplement venir avec
des des petits éléments factuel qui je
crois peuvent éclairer
euh précisément le sujet de de de votre
de votre commission donc je suis venu
avec des tout petits exemples de une 2 3
4 5 6 affair que j'ai eu à connaître
dans le détail en bloc et en détail
comme aurait dit un ancien ministre du
Budget à à à médiap
euh qui à la fois peuvent répondre à la
question que vous vous posez sur la
complicité en quelque sorte de certains
organismes bancaires ou
sur l'apathie ou le l'insuffisance des
contrôles institutionnels face à ce type
de de pratique alors je je je passe
assez vite sur sur la le le premier
exemple vous en entendez beaucoup parler
je crois qu'il a été entendu ce matin à
H clos dans une dans l'assemblée d'à
côté je parle de l'affaire HSBC et les
listings
faltiani nous avons raconté
mdiap l'émission cache investigation
France 2 Comment à un moment donné euh
et cela arrive au carrefour d'une autre
affaire ce qui lui donne un peu son sel
comment
euh un président de commission des
finances dont vous savez bien mieux que
moi quels sont les pouvoirs
d'investigation ils sont absolument
considérable a été destinataire en août
2010 d'informations extrêmement précises
sur les opérations illicites les
pratiques illicites et de blanchiment
euh et de financement occulte de la
banque HSBC ce président de commission
était Jérôme Cusac et que n'a-t-il fait
des information qu'il avait entre les
mains à rien à rien alors plusieurs
raisons peuvent expliquer tout cela
évidemment il était concerné
personnellement par la fraude fiscale
lui-même avait recours au services des
banques pour pouvoir échapper à l'impôt
et dissimuler des avoirs et comme nous
l'avons racontré contrairement à ce
qu'il a dit à une commission d'enquête à
l'Assemblée nationale sur l'affaire qui
porte son nom son frère Antoine kayusac
était bien membre du comité exécutif de
HSBC France au moment de ces fait et
contrairement à ce qu'il dit l'enquête
judiciaire qui a été ouverte et confié
au juges von rumbeck et Charlotte Bilger
pte bien sur les relations entre HSBC
France et HSBC
Genève dans cette affaire on a pu voir
également qui est une autre illustration
je crois euh une leçon de chose de ce
que nous avons pu découvrir des
problèmes permanents
persistants des liens inestueux qui
peuvent exister entre certains pouvoirs
d'enquête et le pouvoir exécutif ou le
cordon ombellical n'est pas coupé et ce
qui pose un certain nombre de problèmes
et j'entendais mon confrère Antoine
payon en parler tout à l'heure quand il
évoquait tracf il a tout à fait raison
tracf est un outil formidable alors qui
marche sur la bonne volonté des
établissements bancaires puisque ce sont
des déclarations de soupçon des banques
qui le remontent mais beaucoup de
banques font remonter beaucoup de
déclarations de de soupçon et il est
exact et je peux en témoigner que
Tracfin ne parfois ne fait pas suivre
certains dossiers ne les judiciarisent
pas et le lien qui peut exister avec le
pouvoir exécutif dans certaines affaires
quand certaines personnalités sont en
cause et
problématique deuxème petit exemple la
ferbe est en cours alors la ferbe est en
cours que certains ont voulu voir sous
l'angle d'une sorte
de récit entre
Balzac et Dallas est aussi l'histoire de
paradis fiscaux il ne faut pas oublier
que nous avons découvert grâce à
l'affaire béancour que madame béancour
n'a jamais été contrôlée n'a jamais été
contrôlé fiscalement ce sont les
déclarations de la comptable CLIRE Tibou
qui ont été confirmé CLIRE Tibou est
resté 15 ans au service de Madame
betancour elle n'a jamais été contrôlée
personnellement par le fisque il a fallu
cet accident de l'histoire
rambolesque les enregistrements du
majordom pour que nous
découvrions l'immensité de la fraude
fiscale de de de la maison
béancour qui ont amené pour la première
fois un contrôle fiscal et la découverte
de 12 comptes non déclarés à l'étranger
l'essentiel un Suisse mais certains à 5
Singapour ce sont au total depuis leur
ouverture des centaines de millions
d'euros qui ont été soustraits au Bien
National au bien commun il a fallu qu'un
majordom prenne sur lui de faire cet
acte que le que l'on peut considéré
déloyal immoral voire
illégal de placer un dictaphone pour
enregistrer les conversations d'affaires
de l'héritière de L'Oréal et espèce de
de de balle de personnage qui
s'intéressaent beaucoup à sa fortune
pour que nous nous découvrions
l'immensité de la fraude fiscale de
Madame béancour pourquoi madame béancour
n'a jamais été contrôlé il avait-il un
Pact tacite entre les pouvoirs
politiques successifs pour ne pas
enquêter sur Madame béancour fiscalement
ce qui toutes les grandes fortunes
normalement sont contrôlé à peu près à
à tous les 3 ans à peu près m pas Madame
béancour pourquoi on voit là un déficit
qui pe être de l'ordre politique ou
culturel et qui n'est pas une question
partisane droite gauche hein tout ce que
je dis là se situe très très très
au-delà d'une ligne de fracture droite
gauche autre exemple l'affaire Cusac
alors je vais pas en parler sous l'angle
dont on en a beaucoup parlé et dont la
rédaction et de miaap et moi-même en
avons fait un livre mais de de dernier
développement apparu grâce à l'enquête
parlementaire qui continue toujours à
l'Assemblée nationale et ça rejoint
alors là en plein
euh ce que mon confrère Antoine
payon a raconté dans son livre vous
savez qu'il a été question dans laffire
B encour de savoir que que connaissait
quel était le degré de connaissance de
l'Élysée et du ministère de l'Intérieur
de de de l'affaire l'affaire qui accord
Tib en cours excusez-moi de degré de
l'affaire il le le patron de de des
services secrets intérieur monsieur
calvare a été entendu à Hu clos il avait
été dit qu'il n'y avait jamais eu de
note blanche finalement monsieur Calvar
a dit que oui il y en avait bien une
mais que Monsieur kayusac n'était pas
cité dedans et finalement cette note
blanche de la dcriri a été donné à la
Commission et a été son contenu a a pu
être connu d'un certain nombre de de de
de journalistes alors c'est vrai que
Monsieur kayusac n'appar pas dans cette
note blanche il y en avait-il une autre
ou pas ça n'est pas du tout l'objet de
nos débat mais qu'est-ce qu'on apprend à
la lecture de cette note qui est quand
même stupéfiant par rapport à ce qui ce
que sont vos vos travaux c'est que
en avril 2009 en avril 2009 la dcrii
savait tout tout des pratiques d'évasion
fiscale de démarchage illicite bancaire
de UBS en Suisse et de sa filiale enfin
pas de sa filiale mais de la de sa de la
banque en France il savait tout et que
s'est-il passé à rien pour quelle raison
l'enquête judiciaire il a fallu le livre
d'Antoine payon notamment pour qu'elle
pour que aujourd'hui elle aboutisse à la
mise en examen et ça n'est pas rien de
la personne morale UBS France et de la
personne morale UBS Suisse ce qui est
suffisamment rare pour être noté car
très souvent ce sont quelques dirigeants
quelques fusibles qui sautent là et
c'est rare judiciaairement ce sont les
personnes morales qui sont mises en
examen dans les affaires de corruption
les affaires de blanchiment de frut
fiscale c'est extrêmement rare
généralement c'est quelque un directeur
financier ici directeur administratif là
parfois un PDG mais rarement la personne
morale ce qui est important parce que la
personne morale on est on est dans le
système on est dans la pratique
institutionnelle privé ou ou publique
entreprise publi peu
importe alors ça pose une
question qui est fondamentale et que moi
je peux croiser
souvent c'est la question peut-être
a-t-elle déjà été évoquée devantre
commission de la l'article
40 des fonctionnaires vous le savez
encore mieux que moi tout agent
dépositaire de l'autorité publique est
alerter le procureur de la République
s'il est té mooins de de crime ou délit
c'est une obligation mais subtilité je
sais pas si ça relève d'une forme de
culture française et de ces dérogations
parfois subtilité c'est une obligation
mais si on ne le fait pas il ne se passe
rien il n'y a pas de sanction si
l'obligation n'est pas respectée alors
je ne sais pas dans la pratique comment
les choses peuvent changer mais le fait
est que l'article 40 qui est un je crois
un bon article code de procédure pénale
d'alerte pour pour saisir les autorités
compétentes sur bah quand voilà un
fonctionnaire est témoin de ce qui
pourrait être un délit notamment
financier notamment de fraude fiscale
pour que la démocratie fonctionne parce
que les institutions prennent le relet
des soupçons les vérifient ou les
infirment peu importe c'est une
obligation mais si elle n'est pas
respectée et ben c'est c'est pas grave
donc peu de gens Infiné utilisent
l'article 40 et il n'y a pas ce ce poids
de de l'autorité quand des
fonctionnaires y compris de la DCRI les
AG des services secrets ne sont pas des
gens à part vis-à-vis de la fonction
publique bon euh une une autre affaire 3
4e on en a entendu parler récemment
alors là on rentre dans on va dire la
cathédrale une cathédrale de subtilité
financière qui qui est l'affaire Hermes
LVMH vous savez comment
LVMH secrètement pendant des années est
monté au capital de Hermes euh et ces
dirigeants ont découvert du jour au
lendemain que alors qu'ils avaient
manqué à leur déclaration à leur
obligation de de de déclaration
vis-à-vis des marchés financiers le VMH
était un actionnaire très important de
de Hermes alors que découvre-t-on dans
dans les documents qui sont des
documents que je peux bien évidemment
vous laisser qui sont connus mais de
l'AMF et cetera c'est tout ça c'est fait
à partir de quoi cette monté secrète
dans le capital de LVMH des paradis
fiscaux des paradis fiscaux de sociétés
lié à LVM j'en ai les preuves ici qui
sont domiciliés au
Panama qui sont domiciliés encore au
Panama toujours au Panama
voilà les documents de lvlm le montrent
pour des opérations sur des sommes
absolument considérables si on fait le
tout petit travail de prendre à combien
l'action a été achetée par l'une de C
ces sociétés qu'elle s'appelle Hannibal
evil Ford business ou aut et que l'on
compare à combien elles ont été vendues
quelques années plus tard jusqu'au
moment où LVMH apparaît comme le réel
propriétaire de tout cela la plusvalue
sur le papier en titre avec un système
financier assez compliqué qui s'appelle
l'equity swap on est à plus d'un
milliard d'euros on est à plus d'un
milliard d'euros le jugement de la MF
vient de tomber et c'est ce que je
voulais dire quelle est l'amende de LVMH
8 million d'euros et l'amende maximale
requise était 100 millions on pouvait
pas aller plus loin que 100 millions
comment voulez-vous qu'il y ait une
pédagogie efficiente qu'il y ait une
autorité réelle qui témoigne d'une
volonté à la fois politique sociale et
culturel de lutter sur ce type de
pratique quand l'amende maximale est de
10 millions la condamnation effective de
l'amende est de 8 millions alors que les
sommes en jeu dépassent le milliard
d'euros je nuris aurait pas l'indescence
ici de de citer le de donner le chiffre
d'affaires de LMH que je ne connais pas
par cœur mais si vous voulez cela me
donne le sentiment comme souvent dans
ces affaires que l'on s'attaque à des
portes blindées avec un plumeau pour les
fracturer un autre exemple l'affaire
takedine alors là
affaire complexe et non pas compliqué
mais complexe si si si elle en est qui
touche à des ramifications sur 20 ans
euh et alors là je vous ai amené un
document qui avait fait l'objet d'un
d'un article de miaap euh en juillet
2012 signé par mon mon éminent confrère
Carl lasquier et moi-même libi sarkoosi
argentnoir les affaires de takedine avec
la barclleays voilà c'est ça qui
m'intéresse la banque barclleays nous
avions récupéré un un document qui fait
je crois 19 pages euh quand monsieur
takidine voulait contracter auprès de la
BAR clay euh des emprunts bancaires et
la barkleay a fait ce qu'on appelle des
due diligence sur la personne pour
savoir s'il lui prête de l'argent ou pas
et donc ils font une sorte d'enquête non
pas de de moralité mais de savoir s'il
est solvable est-ce qu'il peut être
lui-même profitable pour la banque et
cetera et que découvre-t-on à la lecture
de ce rapport que je que je vous laisse
si vous le souhaitez c'est que la
Barclay c'est tout absolument tout des
montages offshore de Monsieur dakedine
de ces techniques de blanchiment des
sociétés écran caché dans d'autres
trustes caché dans des fondations tout
tout est décrit il y a même des schéma
très bien fait et très juste en
l'occurrence et que peut-on lire dans ce
rapport quand on l'a traduit c'est
revenue actu alors petite parenthèse
mais pour vous montrer que la moralité
vraiment ne ne n'est pas
une priorité ses revenus actuels
découlent d'un contrat qu'il a négocié
pour la la fourniture d'équipement de
surveillance électronique au fin de
surveillance des emails et d'Internet
entre les gouvernements français et
libiens ce qui est tout à fait juste il
reste à payer 5 millions d'euros sur ce
contrat pour les 2 ans à venir je dis
simplement cela pourquoi parce que ce
contrat là de vente de matériel
d'espionnage électronique par la France
à la Libye où le principal intermédiaire
était monsieur takidine qui a touché 4,2
millions d'euros de commission via des
structures offshore est aujourd'hui au
cœur de plusieurs enquêtes judiciaires
dont une pour complicité de crime contre
l'humanité car c'est ce système
d'espionnage qui a permis
de grâce notamment au paiements via les
paradis fiscaux d'espionner les
opposants à Monsieur Kaddafi qui était
la première étape avant de les arrêter
de les torturer parfois même de les
tuer alors qu'écrit la barkleay comme on
peut s'y attendre pour un client de la
nature de Ziad ses avoirs sont détenus
par le biais de structure offshore bien
qu'il soit lui et non un trust le
bénéfici direct de chacune en raison de
sa résidence fiscale entre guillemets à
Paris la structure de ses propriétés
d'actif est un peu complexe c'est un
monsieur qui s'appelle William hardf qui
a écrit ça qui ne travaille plus à la
barcl aujourd'hui qui travaille pour le
le vendeur d'armes Adnan cachogi il
écrit notre relation de prêbancaire
passera par la structure aux îles
viierges britannique qui détient la
propriété de Londes de ZAD takedine il
poursuit il est probable que le client
possède des liquidités et des avoirs
au-delà de ce qu'il a déclaré mais il
est réticent à déclarer la totalité de
ses actifs à une tierce partie à ce
stade de la relation avec la banque sa
résidence en France et le régime fiscal
qui lui est associé font qu'il est
prudent quand il discute et ses revenus
et avoir de ses revenus pardon et avoir
imposa donc là vous avez la
démonstration qu'une grande banque qui
s'appelle la Barclay c'est tout des
motivations de fraude fiscale
éventuellement de corruption de
complicité avec des régimes
dictatoriaux de de d'utilisation
d'argent offshore d'un homme monsieur
takidine qui est aujourd'hui sous écrou
dans plusieurs affaires judiciaires dans
lesquelles il est cité donc ces exemples
que j'ai voulu vous donner et il y en a
bien d'autres et ils n'en sont en rien
exhaustifs ils sont forcément
partiels je crois démontre par par
simplement les fait sans sans jugement
ni moral ni ni de quoi que ce soit
quelle est l'immensité du problème qui
est devant nous tous qui sommes attachés
aux questions qui vous qui vous qui vous
anime alors par rapport à tout cela
c'est vrai que pour avoir la chance de
pouvoir rencontrer des magistrats des
enquêteurs des policiers des agents
secrets beaucoup de personnes qui de
près ou de loin sont déteinteurs
d'information d'intérêt public pour nous
journalistes c'est vrai que plusieurs
questions font fondamental se pose que
ce
soit le respect de la protection des
sources dont on pourra reparler si vous
le souhaitez qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
une mince à faire et la nouvelle loi si
elle comporte quelques avancées comporte
aussi toujours une impasse importante
c'est la protection de ces personnes que
l'on appelle aux États-Unis des whistle
blower des lanceurs d'alerte qui sont
absolument fondamentaux dans la
connaissance de la vérité si on part du
principe que dans une démocratie la
transparence doit être la règle et le
secret l'exception que quand on parle
d'argent public dans l'expression argent
public il y a le mot quand même public
et qu'il est normal que nous sachions
tous ce qu'il se passe concernant cet
argent que que l'on se doit les uns aux
autres euh ce qui me remonte beaucoup
également c'est le défaut d'alerte
parfois y compris pour les services
enquêteurs eux-mêmes on on en parlait
tout à l'heure l'article 40 qui est en
réalité très peu
utilisé ça peut être également la
communication la judiciarisation des
découvertes de des chambres régionales
des comptes ou de la Cour des comptes
parce que les temporalités sont pas
toujours les mêmes parce qu'il n'y a pas
toujours une judiciarisation
évidente ça peut être Tracfin comme
Antoine payon ou moi-même l'avons évoqué
ça peut être également vous l'avez vu ça
a été l'enjeu de de de la loi présentée
sur la fraude fiscale ce qui a été
appelé le verrou de Bery qui n'a
toujours pas sauté c'est-à-dire que nous
sommes la seule démocratie la seule
démocratie où l'administration fiscale a
les pleins pouvoirs le monopole absolu
sur la judiciarisation ou non d'un délit
la fraude fiscale ce qui met les les les
magistrats les parquetiers les juges
dans des des situations extravagantes ou
pour pouvoir avoir l'opportunité de
poursuite il faut faut qu'ils aillent
chercher le blanchiment de fraude
fiscale ce qui veut dire des enquêtes
déjà beaucoup plus compliquées parce que
non seulement il faut trouver le délit
mais il faut trouver le moyen du délit
bon comment voulez-vous qu'il y ait une
pédagogie politique culturelle vis-à-vis
de ces affaires si on ne considère pas
que la fraudte fiscale c'est aussi un
délit un un une attaque contre la
société ce qui est le propre quand même
du pénal et que ça ne peut pas
simplement être des questions de
négociation entre un état et des
fraudeurs de de transaction à qui paye
le mieux le plus vite il y a aussi une
charge symbolique et pas c symbolique
important dans la judiciarisation de de
de ces affaires ça c'est à main gauche
et j'en termine à main droite une fois
qu'il y a les affaires alors là je sais
qu'on va toucher un
domaine compliqué dont je n'ai
évidemment pas les réponse mais que se
passe-t-il en terme d'exemplarité on le
voit trop souvent il y a encore des
exemples très récents quand des hommes
politiques par exemple sont condamnés
dans des faits de frautee fiscale de de
corruption ils se représentent ils sont
élus confè Gaston Flos confè monsieur
Bédier qui n'est pas encore réélu mais
qui a fait 45 % en premier tour si je ne
me trompe pas donc je trouve que ce
petit panorama là nous montre quand même
un paysage assez
dévasté vis-à-vis de ce que peut être
euh la culture des démocratique
vis-à-vis de ces questions qui ne sont
encore une fois pas des questions
annexes de notre vie quotidienne elles
sont au cœur de notre vie quotidienne et
c'est vrai que pour nous journalistes
c'est dur de sensibiliser l'opinion
publique au-delà du
caractère scandaleux sulfureux et
spectaculaire de certaines affaires sur
ces questions parce qu'il est vrai que
l'opinion c'est aussi un muscle et
que il est important que je crois chacun
puisse considérer au-delà encore une
fois des questions partisanes droite
gauche parce que cet argent là cet
argent public il est pas de gauche ni de
droite hein c'est nos crèches nos écoles
enfin vous savez tout ça
bon voilà et c'est pourquoi
mdiapart qui est un tout petit
laboratoire s'emploie à essayer le plus
sincèrement possible de mettre sur la
table des information d'intérêt public
qui sont susceptibles de nourrir cette
conversation merci beaucoup la parole
est à notre apporteur merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur Harfi de ce
préambule extrêmement documenté et très
intéressant je partage je crois que
c'est l'ensemble de mes collègues le
souci que vous avez de la
pédagogie vous parlez de culture
démocratique j'aime bien l'expression
mais je pense que chacun à nos places
respectives nous avons cette
responsabilité commune nous portons
cette préoccupation d'effectivement de
porter à la connaissance du du plus
large public en tout cas c'est notre
souhait l'analyse la compréhension et et
la la la transparence finalement c'est
c'est c'est là notre fonction
essentielle et puis bien sûr des
propositions et des solutions pour agir
euh vous avez parlé de plusieurs
dossiers plusieurs cas connus impliquant
des
personnalités dont il est beaucoup
question depuis plusieurs années dans
beaucoup de cas mais j'aimerais
également que vous donniez des des
informations si tentz que vous en ayez
ou des éléments de de d'éclairage sur le
rôle qu'on pu jouer dans tous ces
montages dans tous ces systèmes le les
opérateurs structures financier par
exemple vous avez évoqué donc les
paradis fiscaux effectivement il y a il
y a les acteurs il y a les lieux les
décors et puis il y a les montages y a
les mécanique un peu qui est au cœur de
nos préoccupations de cette commission
d'enquête donc euh sur tous les affaires
de sur lesquelles vous avez pu enquêter
ou être ou être informé et quels
établissements financiers concrètement
français ou étrangers avez-vous croisé
dans vos investigations euh alors pour
répondre à la dernière question je crois
pouvoir dire très sincèrement d'avoir
croisé le nom d'à peu près
tous les établissements financiers
connus de la place et ceux qui sont
également moins connus qu' soi français
ou étrangers il suffit d'ailleurs de
regarder la liste des filiales dans les
paradis fiscaux d'un certain nombre
d'établissements bancaires français ou
ou ou étrangers des association
travaille
dessus je pense au CCFD Terre solidaire
ou d'autres qui ont fait des rapports
très précis sur ce type de de pratique
où le le le Tax network justice qui
travaille beaucoup d'ailleurs avec
Nicolas shacson que je
citais tout à l'heure alors sur les
pratiques moi je ne suis pas un un un
spécialiste et un praticien de tout cela
et vous avez entendu je crois des gens
qui ont été au cœur de cette industrie
de la fraude fiscale mais c'est vrai que
on constate que en cela on est dans une
forme de je vais volontairement outrer
mon propos mais de mafia
financière puisque comme dans le crime
organisé on découvre que que ils
s'adapte toujours aux nouvelles
législations ils arrivent toujours à
contourner le nouveau texte futile de
plus en plus répressif toujours avec une
technicité toujours plus élaborée et
face à ces pratiques là des comp des
complexités diplomatiques des
complications judiciaires une
lenteur qui permet au crimes financiers
de de prospérer alors les techniques
elles sont extrêmement
nombreus l'affaire Cusac nous a permis
de découvrir comment il pouvait exister
ce qu'on appelle des comptes omnibus ou
des comptes maîtres ou des Master à
compte dans des banques c'est-à-dire que
le l'ayantroit réel d'un compte en
banque ou le bénéficiaire économique peu
importe n'apparaît pas dans les livres
de comptes de la banque puisqu'il est
dissimulé dans un nuage de compte dont
l'yantroit est une société de gestion la
société rail et compagnie qui n'est
devenue une banque qu'en novembre 2010
contrairement à ce qu'on peut entendre
avant novembre 2010 elle n'avait pas de
licence bancaire était réputé pour pour
ce type de de de
pratique vous avez je crois reçu
quelqu'un qui a été un praticien hein
Monsieur Pierre Condamin Gerbier qui
au-delà de ses déclarations sur les les
les les stings politiques éventuellement
de de eur
euh explique je crois assez bien ce que
peut être un certain nombre de pratiques
par exemple les je sais pas les les
prêts les prêts Lombards ce qu'on
appelle les prêts back to back ou
comment on fait de la garantie d'actif
entre de banques l'une avec des avoirs
non déclarés l'autre avec des avoirs
déclarés
euh voilà les les les stratégies
financières sont permanentes alors
évidemment la le trust la fondation
litenstein
l'anchelat euh la cascade de société de
de portage euh c'est pour ça que je
prenais tout à l'heure un peu l'image du
plumeau pour pour fracturer une porte
blindée c'est-à-dire que il y a des gens
qui sont surarmés et en face des
administrations parfois euh euh
maloutillé à de très bonne volonté mais
mal outillé et donc la question qui se
pose c'est comment euh se battre à arm
égal pour pouvoir percer à la fois cette
énorme puissance financière et cette
mobilité cette mobilité permanente vous
vous le voyez le vous parlez de la
géographie mais chaque année quasiment
la la la place forte du du offshore
bouge un jour c'est Singapour et puis
c'est Hong Kong et puis c'est euh euh
les les paradis fiscaux insulaires et
puis c'est encore un autre parce que
chacun a sa petite spécificité chacun a
trouver euh le petit truc et astuce qui
lui permet euh d'être premier de la
rliste sur ce type de pratique nous
sommes évidemment preneurs des documents
que vous nous avez proposé de nous
remettre qui sans doute auront de
l'intérêt dans dans nos travaux et notre
information sur la la supervision qui
est aussi une préoccupation que nous
avons et nous investiguons sur ce sujet
de manière récurrente quels sont les
grandes défaillances à vos
yeux en matière de supervision de la
part des autorités en charge en matière
d'enquête avez-vous pu identifier dans
vos travaux et si les informations
auxquelles vous avez pu avoir accès vous
pensez-vous que les les services de la
public au sens large et pu eux aussi en
avoir connaissance de la même manière
alors oui parce
que je j'ai souvent pu constater que
quand on veut savoir on peut savoir et
l'affaire kusac a été de ce point de
vue un un enseignement quasi caricatural
d'ailleurs à beaucoup de points de vue
mais rendez-vous compte que nous alors
que nous sommes pas meilleurs qu'un que
d'autres he avec un calpin un stylo et
un tout petit peu de jugjotte on a
réussi à retrouver ce compte ces comptes
de Monsieur kahusac peut-être il y en
a-t-il encore
d'autres là où après leur révélation
l'administration fiscale Bery la DG
FIP non seulement n'a pas trouvé le
compte que nous avions déjà révélé mais
a dit qu'il n'y en avait
pas alors je sais pas si c'est de
l'incompétence ou de la complicité c'est
pas mon mon souci mais je constate que
avec les mêmes éléments d'information
c'est-à-dire ceux de médiap la DG FIP a
conclu qu'il n'y avait pas de compte
comme nous l'avions dit et que la
justice a conclu qu'il y en avait bien
un lafip a trouvé le contraire de la
vérité quand la justice quelques
semaines après a trouvé la vérité alors
je rentre pas dans le débat de
l'opportunité de l'enquête parallèle
dont on a découvert d'ailleurs depuis
qu'elle a été fait quand même dans le
dos de la justice ce qui a révélé le
procureur de la République de de Paris
qui n'était pas au courant de de ces
investigations administra alors que la
justice enquêtait
déjà Antoine payon est bien plus
compétent que moi sur la question mais
il est vrai que les services de
renseignement français sont très bien
renseignés c'est vrai c'est exact que la
dcriri que les douanes compris la DGSE a
beaucoup d'information la question qui
se pose c'est comment
pouvons-nous quand les délis sont
constater sont là le soupçon est
suffisamment fort pour le judiciariser
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure l'article
40 me paraît être un outil formidable
mais dont on c'est un bâton dont on a
déjà quasiment cassé le manche si vous
voulez donc une obligation dont le dont
le non respect n'est pas sanctionné est
un est un est un est un nonsens est-ce
qu'on peut imaginer que la DCRI dispose
d'informations que la DG FIP par exemple
ne pourrait avoir en sa possession
est-ce que c'est
imaginable je je je je crois pouvoir
dire que c'est plus qu'imaginable mais
c'est euh le cas c'est le cas je suis je
suis pas certain que du côté de la
dgifip on ait on a eu cette finesse dans
la
connaissance des stratégies de
blanchiment de la banque UBS pourquoi il
y a-t-il une enquête après dans ce
cas-là c'est c'est
une une enquête judiciaire vous voulez
dire mais parce que au bout d'un moment
quand les fait une enquête de
l'intérieur sur le sujet de l'intérieur
une enquête de l'intérieur mais parce
que il y a au sein de la DCRI une une
sous-direction qui s'appelle la
sous-direction k au sein de laquelle il
y a une section qui s'appelle la section
K5 dont précisément je pourrais vous en
donner un organigramme si vous le voulez
dont précisément le le travail consiste
à à traquer le le le blanchiment et qui
concerne les activités
bancaires et de par le la qualité du
travail des agents de la dessérique
parce qu' encore une fois il s'agit pas
de dire qu'on a une administration
incompétente puce que ça n'est pas le
cas ça n'est pas le cas je je veux dire
que nous certaines informations que nous
nous pouvons révéler nous ne les sortons
pas notre chapeau on n'invente pas les
choses il s'agit pas de dire que les
services de renseignement sont sont son
nos sources mais je peux ici témoigner
que souvent j'ai
croisé des des des des sur mon sur le
chemin de mes enquêtes qui sont très
artisanales pas de fait des
fonctionnaires qui qui eux aussi avaient
eu le soupçon l'affaire Cusac de ce
point de vuel est formidable en 2001 le
fils qui avait déjà été alerté en 2008
le fils qui a été
alert et il a fallu les révélations de
miaap bien que la DG FIP a trouvé le
contraire de la vérité pour que enfin
grâce au travail de la justice et au
moyens qui sont les siens on ait pu
trouver les comptes encore que encore
que il s'en est fallu de peu pour que la
justice ne trouve pas les comptes
pourquoi parce que le blanchiment de
fraude fiscale ne suffit pas pour la
Suisse pour coopérer judiciaairement
avec la France c'est parce que dans la
demande d'entraide pénale du parquet de
par il y a eu un adindum sur blanchiment
de frutee fiscale plus les activités de
Monsieur cayusac lié au laboratoire lié
au laboratoire que la Suisse s'est
décidé à répondre à la France le
blanchiment de fraude fiscale en soi qui
pour nous est un crime financier pour la
Suisse ça ne suffisait pas pour qu'elle
coopère et heureusement que miapart
avait de ce point de vue-l raconté dès
le mois de décembre quels étaient les
liens de Monsieur kahusac avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique son lobbying
les activités conseil ça la justice
n'aurait pas découvert les fait et le
mensonge aurait été aujourd'hui une
vérité madame Gou
oui je vous remercie de votre de votre
intervention qui est un vraiment une une
illustration du sujet de de cette saison
2 qui sont les banques cette fois-ci et
pas seulement bon donc bon évidemment
les questions vont un peu se répéter euh
nous avons dans quelques jours un texte
sur la transparence de la vie publique
et pas seulement de la vie
politique est-ce que vous pensez que ce
texte est nécessaire et suffisant est-ce
que vous vous pensez que c'est déjà une
avancée moi j'ai une question à vous
poser sur la la
publication les déclarations de
patrimoine des
élus moi j'aimerais votre œil de
journaliste parce que nous sommes alors
c'est un tout petit peu en marge et
j'espère que le président pardonnera
mais c'est d'un actualité brûlante pour
ce qui concerne les travaux de notre
maison euh moi je suis un peu inquiète
quant à la publication parce que la
publication peut nous amener évidemment
à à à des débordements multiples et
variés qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la
publication du patrimoine telle qu'elle
est prévu par par le texte et la
deuxième chose qui qui m'intéresse
au-delà de de dizaine d'autres questions
qu'on pourrait qu'on pourrait vous poser
euh c'est la la formation de de nos de
nos agents parce que la semaine dernière
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que nous
avons reçu Dominique stroscan qui nous a
expliqué dans des termes un peu
différent mais en fait ce que vous venez
de nous dire à savoir que en matière de
fraude fiscale on jouait au football
avec des règles sur un terrain de basket
enfin en gros donc on il y avait quand
même une une distorsion énorme entre le
la la la réalité des choses et les
moyens qu'on y mettait pouron donc moi
j'aimerais savoir si dans le cours de
vos investigations euh vous vous avez
relevé des carences manifestes
euh de formation des des des personnels
que vous avez pu rencontrer ou des des
agents et et enfin si vous avez une
seule
préconisation à faire pour les textes
qui viennent sur la transparence de la
vie publique dans quelques jours et sur
la fraude et l'évasion fiscal dans 2
semaines quelles seraient ces
préconisations alors merci prtion alors
moi je je n'ai pas du tout euh ni le
désir ni la vocation de sortir de de de
de de mon rôle mais je vais quand même
essayer de de répondre le plus euh
simplement possible alors sur la loi sur
la sur la transparence bon sincèrement
je ne suis pas arbitre des élégances
législatives ou ou ou parlementaires
euh cela étant
euh le fait est que je ne crois pas que
euh euh resserrer un peu le boulot sur
les déclarations de patrimoine aurait
fait que Monsieur kusac aurait inscrit
ses con Suiss dedans bon cela étant cela
étant cela
étant comme je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure je pars du
principe peut-être suis-je plus proche
d'une sorte de culture anglosaxonne de
ce point de vue là que française que
quand on est un homme public on doit
rendre des comptes bon est-ce que il
faut rendre public les patrimoines
sincèrement je n'ai aucune religion sur
la question je je ne sais pas la
pratique montrera si si c'est valable ou
pas s'il y aura des débordement ou pas
ça existe dans des d'utres démocraties
sans que ça provoque une culture du du
du du du voyurisme cela étant il est
tout à fait normal qu'il y ait des
autorités qu'il ait des pouvoirs
d'investigation et de contrôle pour voir
s'il y a des enrichissement des
évolutions anormales de patrimoine de
personnes qui vivent de l'argent du
peuple bon du public
euh alors c'est marrant parce que
j'étais venu avec un un c'est passé un
peu inaperçu mais c'est un billet de
blog de l'ancienne correspondante de
Radio France à aux États-Unis qui
s'appelle Fabienne saintè qui est revenu
à Paris et qui avait un blog très bien
et qui avait réagi à l'affaire kusac dès
le 5 avril donc c'est de jours après les
aveux de Monsieur kusac et elle avait
fait un billet très instructif qui
s'appelait si Jérôme causa qui était
américain et qui et qui répond en plein
à à vos à votre questionnement et même
au questionnement de le sujet de la
Commission et elle a raconé ce ce ce ce
système qui s'appelle le veting process
aux États-Unis qui veut dire passer au
crible c'est-à-dire comment chaque
ministre chaque juge y compris même de
la Cour suprême chaque haut
fonctionnaire doit accepter
pardonnez-moi l'expression mais c'est la
sienne de se mettre à poil avant
de prendre un poste aussi important elle
elle elle elle donne la liste des 63
questions qui sont posées comment
l'administration et pluse les les
déclarations fiscales sur les 10
dernières années sur le patrimoine
comment comment il y a une culture aux
États-Unis du parjure notamment de la
parole publique je pense que par exemple
ce ne serait pas absurde de créer un
délite par jure
euh pour pour les hommes pour les hommes
publics y compris pour ceux qui
témoignent dans des procédures
judiciaires hein que un homme politique
entend endu et que sur PV il mente et
qu'on découvre par les développement de
l'enquête qu'il a menti et ben qu'il a
un délit par jure je trouve pas ça
complètement extravagant le fait est que
si le vetting process à l'américaine
avait été appliqué à Monsieur kusac
monsieur kusac n'aurait jamais été
ministre du
Budget peut-être parlementaire mais pas
ministre du Budget c'estàd que nous
n'aurions pas eu cette situation
renversante d'un homme dont la charge
publique est de lutter contre la fraude
fiscale qui est lui même un frudur
fiscal depuis plus de 20 ans voilà alors
est-ce que le viting process à
l'américaine est est applicable et
transposable en tant que tel en France
je ne sais pas mais je pense qu'il n'est
pas interdit de de s'y
intéresser plus
globalement moi je comment dire
je vous me demandez est-ce qu'il y a des
avancées dans la loi les différentes
lois qui peut y avoir contre la lutte
contre la FRE fiscale et la transparence
c'est une évidence qu'il y a des
avancées
mais comment dire ça fait 30 ans qu'il y
a des avancées ça fait 30 ans qu'on fait
des lois sur la transparence le
financement des partis politiques la
lutte contre la fraude fiscale donc la
question n'est pas de d'être le
comptable à mon avis des avancé c'est
que au bout d'un moment et je crois
enfin que nombreuses personnes partagent
ce sentiment c'est que ça suffit ça
suffit qu'il y ait des nouvelles grandes
lois et que ça ne change rien alors bien
sûr qu'il y a des avancées effectives
mais il y a aussi des statut quo je
trouve insupportable euh j'en parlais
tout à l'heure l'article 40 mais la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme ne
cesse de nous le dire le lien ineseux
entre le pouvoir politique et et le
pouvoir judiciaire la séparation des
pouvoirs n'est pas totalement effective
dans notre pays et ça n'est pas être
excité que de dire ça et de monter sur
la table avec un couteau entre les dents
des magistrats très respectables de la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme ne
cessent de le dire à la France les
parquets ne sont pas des vrais autorités
judiciaires parce qu'elles ne sont pas
indépendantes et toutes les affaires
dont je parle ici toutes les affaires
dont je parle ici quand elles étaient
entre les mains de procureur qui étaient
lié hiérarchiquement soumis
hiérarchiquement au pouvoir exécutif
avait du mal à prospérer avait du mal à
prospérer est-ce que c'est une question
d'autocensure personnelle des des
magistrats de pudeur de je ne sais pas
mais quand elles sont arrivées entre les
mains de juges indépendant elles ont
prospéré regardez l'exemple caricatural
de l'affaire béoncour le le procureur
courroi celui-là même qui avait reçu
l'ordre national du Mérite lequel des
mains de Monsieur Sarkozy a déployé une
énergie considérable pour ne rien
découvrir y compris sur la fraude
fiscale de Madame bé encour quand les
juges qui ont récupéré l'enquête
indépendant on réussi à découvrir les
des faits alors qu'il y ait un débat
juridique aujourd'hui sur les charges
qui pè sur les uns ou sur les autres
c'est une autre histoire ça et c'est
normal qu'il a des débats juridiques et
moi je suis pas là pour dire si un tel
un tel est coupable pénalement mon
métier ne consiste pas à juger
moralement les gens ni les sources ni à
dire ça ça c'est vous vous êtes
condamnable judiciairement ou vous vous
l'êtes pas le métier de la justice en
revanche de mettre des faits et les fait
parfois recouvre des qualifications
pénales parfois pas parfois les
procédures judiciaires s'éteignent parce
qu'il y a la prescription parce que il
est dur de caractériser certains délits
enfin bon ça c'est l'histoire ensuite de
la de la justice mais le lien inestueux
du pouvoir exécutif que nous avons en
France avec les pouvoirs d'enquête que
ce soit le parquet que ce soit Tracfin
Tracfin est sous l'autorité directe du
ministre de l'économie et des
finances bon et je peux vous dire que il
existe
beaucoup de signalement Tracfin qui ne
sont pas transmis parce
que bah la personne concernée est liée à
un tel ou un tel et que nous n'avons
aucun aucune culture du contrepouvoir
institutionnel auss peu dans notre pays
dans nos propres institutions on ne sait
pas ce qui se passe sans parler de la
tragédie du secret défense dans ce pays
ou bon le secret défense est utilisé à
toutes les sauces pour pouvoir cacher
les turpitudes personnelles de de de
certains je déborde un peu mais parce
que c'est ce que je rencontre en
permanence alors bien sûr qu'il faut du
secret défense bien sûr qu'il faut
protéger les intérêts supérieurs de la
nation mais le problème c'est que moi
très souvent dans des affaires je
constate que quand il y a une
déclassification de documents classifiés
un ministre dit nous avons tout
déclassifié et que 6 mois après il y a
une nouvelle déclassification de
documents donc c'est que la première
fois tout n'avait pas été déclassifié et
qu'on a aucun moyen de savoir quand je
dis on c'est même les juges les juges
n'ont pas le moyen de savoir si ce qui
leur est proposé correspond à la
totalité de ce qui est suc vous avez des
exemples précis l'affaire Karachi de ce
point de vue-là est est un exemple
formidable c'est qu'il y a eu plusieurs
vagues de déclassification à chaque fois
on a entendu nous avons tout
déclassifié le problème du secret défens
si si ça vous intéresse c'est que c'est
un jeu de dupe institutionnel organisé
comment ça se passe très rapidement un
juge
euh pense que la DGSE a des informations
susceptibles d'intéresser son enquête
que fait-il il écrit au ministre de la
Défense en lui disant Monsieur Merci de
me communiquer tous les documents de la
DGSE susceptible d'intéresser mon
enquête le ministre donne le papier au
directeur de la DGSE ils vont dans les
archives la DGSE et choisi c'est eux qui
choisissent les documents qui soumettent
à la commission consultative du crée la
défense nationale qui est un qui qui
rend un avis consultatif mais la
Commission ne vérifie
jamais que la DGSE a fourni tous les
documents susceptibles d'intéresser
l'enquête et ensuite c'est le ministre
qui décide si on déclassifie a si on
déclassifie pas donc c'est le pouvoir
politique qui a le dernier mot sur le
pouvoir judiciaire c'est un principe
complètement
anticonstitutionnel dans d'autres pays
en Angleterre par exemple le le principe
est inverse il existe des juridictions
du secret et c'est au gouvernement
d'expliquer au juges pourquoi tel
document ne doit pas être dans son
enquête c'est c'est l'inverse c'est
l'inverse donc je c'est un c'est un
petit exemple le secret défense mais
c'est comme ça que nous découvrons dans
les affaires que on a déclassifié des
notes qui sont des fond de tiroir des
miettes absolument pas intéressantes et
parce que tel ou tel acteur a décidé de
témoigner ou tel ou tel journaliste a
découvert tel ou tel fait bah on
déclassifie des nouvelles notes donc
c'est bien que on n' pas donné à la
Commission de déclassification
l'ensemble des notes suscepti de
d'intéresser l'enquête bon
euh voilà voilà quelques problèmes qui
sont à la fois je crois technique et
culturel euh
sur la pratique et la lutte contre ce
cette tragédie que sont les paradis
fiscaux la corruption le blanchiment
l'argent
salale avant avant une dernière question
de de de notre rapporteur vous vous êtes
en possession des des des informations
que Monsieur Condamin Gerbier nominative
n'a pas donné à la commission
euh comme il se trouve que nous avons
publié euh cet après-midi euh un début
de grand entretien avec Monsieur
Condamin Gerbier car nous l'avons vu le
29 mai à Genève pendant 6h euh où il
nous a donné un certain nombre
d'informations un entretien enregistré
que lui-même dit avoir fait un peu comme
une assurance vie parce qu'il avait été
destinataire d'un certain nombre de
menaces anonymes à la fois le vis lui
mais aussi sa famille en France qui
était une ambiance un peu Glo si vous me
permettez le le l'expression euh comme
Edou Plenel l'a déjà dit d'ailleurs sur
le plateau de je crois l'émission
motcroisé sur France 2 oui nous avons
été destinataire d'information
concernant des hommes politiques alors
contrairement à ce qui est dit il ne
s'agit pas de liste il n'y a pas il y a
pas une liste avec des numéros de
comptees c'est
c'est plutôt des des recoupements
monsieur Condamin Gerbier a été dans sa
carrière témoin plus ou moins direct
d'un certain nombre de pratiques mais
miapart ne publiera pas ses noms tant
que nous n'avons pas contreenquêté
dessus tant que nous n'avons pas des
éléments au-delà de la la parole d'une
personne voilà donc nous ne jetons pas
en pâure des noms comme ça dans la
sphère publique sous prétexte que telle
ou telle personne a dit euh les avoirs
j'espère que je répond sans trop trahir
voilà alors la dernière question de
notre rapporteur oui tout d'abord une
suggestion les sources avec lesquelles
vous avez été amené à travailler ces
derniers temps sur ce sujet euh si
d'aventure elle souhaitait s'exprimer
librement sur l'espace participatif du
Sénat il y a un site dédié à cette
commission d'enquête surtout qu'elle
n'hésite pas à le faire nous sommes
preneurs d'information euh et justement
à propos de la presse qui a évidemment
un rôle important dans les démocraties
c'est une c'est
mais cela dit la presse c'est pas
homogène je veux dire vous le travail
que vous avez mené méia parté un Journal
du Dimanche de fin janvier qui quasiment
blanchissait la même personne je veux
dire on a des attitudes assez opposé qui
disait que nous avions lancé une
nouvelle affaire clstream on oublit
toujours la deuxè partie du paquet quel
est votre appréciation là-dessus la
presse est pas homogène sur ce sujet non
mais bon moi je bon je je sincèrement je
viens pas dans une incinte aussi
respectable pour faire l'arbitre des
élégances de de de la presse et cetera
moi je peux simplement parler peut-être
c'est un témoignage en creux vis-à-vis
des autres mais de ce qui'est l'histoire
de mdiapart voilà moi je parce que comme
je l'ai raconté avec d'autres dans le
livre que nous avons consacré à
l'affaire
Cahusac je je ne sais que trop bien
quelle est la valeur immense de beaucoup
de mes confrères dans d'autres
rédactions et dans l'affaire kahusac
nous avions créé une sorte de petit pool
informelle de journalistes qui se
réunissait souvent le vendredi soir dans
un café à côté du Louvre au au plus fort
de l'affaire hein quand nous étions le
pire du journalisme euh et le fait est
que il n'y a que méiaap qui a réussi à
publier des informations pas les autres
alors que nous mutualisions l'enquête
nous mutualisions les les les les les
informations pourquoi ce sont des
questions à à à
poser aux responsables des rédactions
concernées mais peut-être il y a-t-il
des réponses toutes simples la situation
capitalistique de la France de de la
presse en France est extrêmement
compliqué je veux dire encore une fois
là ça n'est pas des un discours ni
idéologique ou partisan mais quand vous
avez des grands capitaines d'industrie
dont le le cœur de l'activité n'est pas
l'information qui achète des journaux et
qui pour partie vivent de la commande
publique pour leurs activités ça ne crée
pas un écosystème journalistique je
crois extrêmement sain voilà
euh sans compter une situation
médiatique voilà de journaux qui vont
très mal qui sont
subventionnés au-delà du du du
raisonnable bon méiaap part modestement
a essayer de tracer un chemin différent
de dire nous on ne cherche pas
l'audience on cherche le public on
cherche la qualité l'indépendance totale
nous ne répondons que de la confiance de
nos lecteurs aucune publicité et oui
l'information doit être payante car elle
a car elle a une une une valeur mais
pour aller un peu plus loin et décentrer
un tout petit peu euh en revanche sur la
pratique
journalistique euh nous ne pouvons pas
faire ce que nous faisons si nous
n'avons pas ce bien sacré euh le plus
commun qui est la protection des sources
et ça n'est pas une un réflexe
corporatiste souvent on a l'impression
euh euh à tort mais peut-être aussi des
journalistes ont le ont le on l'explique
mal que euh les revendications liées à
la protection des sources euh une
revendication corporatiste un peu sur le
mode euh on protège nos sources
laissez-nous tranquilles pour qu'on
puisse écrire ce qu'on veut mais c'est
c'est pas ça qu'il faut entendre dans le
mot protection des sources il faut
entendre le mot source la protection des
sources c'est pas une liberté des
journalistes c'est une liberté des
citoyens c'est une liberté donné à
chacun à chacun qu'il soit pharmacien
boulanger agent secret fonctionnaire ce
que vous voulait d'un jour venir alerter
la presse sur des informations qu'il
pense importantes et d'intérêt public
parce que il n'a pas pu faire prospérer
tout cela dans une administration ou
ailleurs et c'est à nous journalistes
d'assumer la responsabilité et les
conséquences de tout cela ça n'est pas
aux sources qui parfois se mettent en
danger professionnellement parfois
physiquement quand elles viennent nous
parler c'est à nous d'assumer y compris
devant les tribunaux parce qu'on n pas
évidemment au-dessus des lois c'est à
nous de répondre de nos écrits devant la
loi pas aux sources pas aux sources les
sources peuvent parfois tenter de nous
manipuler les sources parfois nous
donnent des informations à 80 % justes à
20 % fauses c'est à nous de faire le tri
c'est à nous de vérifier si c'est vrai
ou si c'est faux et le seul critère qui
qui est le nôre c'est si l'information
est vraie et d'intérêt public nous la
publions nous la publions mais nous
devons protéger les sources et c'est à
nous d'assumer c'est pour ça que la loi
sur la protection des sources est
extrêmement importante et que
malheureusement malheureusement alors il
y a eu des discussions au Conseil d'État
la Cour de cassation que on a maintenu
cette idée de d'intérêt supérieur de la
nation qui permettrait à tel ou tel
pouvoir exécutif de porter atteinte aux
sources c'est un problème puisque cette
définition de l'intérêt supérieur est
est trop
lâche où où fixons-nous l'intérêt
supérieur de la nation est-ce que euh le
fait de déstabiliser un gouvernement en
révélant les avoirs occules d'un
ministre du Budget euh relève de cela
bon chacun mais le curseur a un endroit
différent et c'est vrai que de ce point
de vue même s'il y a de vraies
évolutions dans la loi il y a encore une
impasse qui est euh un problème dans la
pratique de notre métier et encore une
une fois pas pour des questions de
corporatisme c'est pas la question pour
des questions démocratiques et je cite
encore cette juridiction supranationale
qui est quand même la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme qui dit que le
secret des sources c'est la pierre
angulaire la pierre angulaire du travail
démocratique des journalistes on a bien
entendu le message voilà mais pour ne
pas avoir de regret et avec l'accord du
rapporteur je donner la parole à notre
collègue qui était en séance et qui ne
pouvait poser cette question maintenant
merci Monsieur moi j'ai une question
très terre à terre est-ce que les
journalistes qui enquêtai ces derniers
temps sur ce sujet ont eu des soucis
type cambriolage type ordinateur
portable volé et cetera ou pas
j'aimerais avoir des des informations
sur ce sujet merci
alors il y a ce qui s'est passé ce qu'on
croit savoir et ce qui peut arriver
techniquement ce qui est parfois
différent ce qui s'est
passé le fait est que c'était sous une
autre présidence mais médiap part nous
pouvons témoigner que nous avons été
cambriolés au plus fort de laffire bé en
cour au même moment où un journaliste du
point qui travaillait sur la ferbé d'cs
s'est fait cambrioler ou un journaliste
du Monde qui travaillait sur la ferbé
d'cs s'est fait cambrioler bon des
plaines ont été déposé le cambolage
avait l'air extrêmement professionnel et
je m'étais fait dérober au journal une
copie des enregistrements du du du
majordom nous savons nous l'avons écrit
que nous avons été surveillé y compris
par la DC qui parfois malheureusement
était devenu une sorte de brigade du
chef à une autre époque nous l'avons
écrit euh une personne que nous
désignons dans cette enquête comme étant
celui qui a l'Élysée piloter cette
surveillance d'État monsieur Claude Guan
avait déposé plainte en diffamation
contre nous ce qui est son droit le plus
ultime et quelques jours avant le procès
dans la torpeur de l'été a retiré sa
plainte au même moment le Canard
Enchaîné avait révélé exactement les
mêmes faits et un livre qui s'appelle
l'espion du président avait encore
amplifié la dimension de ces
informations puisqu'il avait donné des
éléments extrêmement précis sur la
surveillance dans meddiapart a pu être
l'objet ensuite il y a ce qu'on croit
savoir ou ce qu'on nous dit tel ou tel
interlocuteur lié à tel ou tel service
qui nous demande d'être toujours très
prudent voilà enlever la puce du
téléphone ou quand on a comme ça un
iPhone ne pas le prendre parce qu'on
peut pas enlever toujours la Buce ou la
batterie et cetera voilà bon moi
sincèrement je pars du principe que je
ne deviendrai
jamais paranoïque sinon pourra jamais
faire ce ce ce ce métier et ensuite il y
a ce que ce qu'il est techniquement
possible voilà et je crois que l'affaire
Snowden et les révélations du gardien
montre ce qu'il est techniquement
possible et de de ce point de vue de ce
point de vue euh les États et les
responsables politiques des
gouvernements espionnés si on en croit
le le spile et et le gardien ont raison
de pousser des cris d'Orfa mais il
aurait été je
crois juste de pousser les mêmes cris
d'orfraé quand il y avait l'espionnage
de population notamment quand la France
vendait du du matériel
d'espionnage
informatique contre les populations
libyennes ou syriennes à une époque où
nous étions les amis ces dictatures
alors je pense que on va réalimenter le
débat mais là vraiment je vous le
promets c'est la dernière question mais
dernière question est simplement est-ce
que vous avez été en mesure d'exploiter
les données récemment publiées dans
l'enquête offshore leak alors l'histoire
offshore
leaks il se trouve que le le journal qui
a été partenaire de offshore leaks c'est
c'est le monde ça n'a pas été Médiapart
alors c'est vrai que nous étions sur
beaucoup d'autres fronts que c'était un
travail monumental bien que Carl lasquet
et moi-même soyons membres de de
l'issige qui est une
organisation formidable sincèrement de
d'intelligence et de mutualisation du du
travail il se trouve que un certain
nombre de données de offshore leaks ont
été rendu publi alors en France c'est
vrai que des questions se enfin bon je
sais que les révélations par exemple du
gardian concernant charlix encore lui le
gardien ont provoqué un un débat
politique considérable peut-être parce
que beaucoup de de paradis fiscaux sont
liés historiquement et même
institutionnellement parfois à la
Couronne britannique bon
euh en France ça a été un peu un peu
moins le cas bien queil y ait eu des
informations importantes révélées
notamment par nos nos nos nos confrères
du monde mais l'exploitation des données
qui pour certaines ont été rendu publies
sont très très lente voilà très lente et
très patiente parce que c'est un travail
de de de de de de d'anacorette quoi
voilà de bénédictin comme ça pour
pouvoir croiser les informations parce
que jamais tout cela n'arrive sur sur un
plateau et précisément tout est organisé
tout est organisé par cascade de société
de comptte d'Ant droit cachés pour que
nous ne trouvions pas nous journalistes
enquêteurs enfin peu importe
hein merci merci une deuxè ou une troisè
fois merci merci à vous
merci voilà pour les travaux de la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur le
rôle des banques dans l'évasion fiscale
si vous souhaitez les revoir ou en
savoir plus sur ce thème notre site
internet
publsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous avec
les travaux parlementaires c'est cet
après-midi à partir de 16h30 vous
pourrez suivre la séance consacré cet
après-midi à la réforme du CSM le
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
bonne journée à
tous